so AOC tweets about uh hate crimes going
on the that hate crimes will be on the
rise because some billionaire with an
ego unilaterally controls a massive
communication platform and Elon Musk
says stop hitting on me I'm really shy
in one of the most epic clap backs and
smackdowns and the internet is in uproar
the far right is pouncing they're all
throwing their arms in there and
cheering while the left is outraged and
saying real real mature Elon oh the
internet is back baby it's like good old
2015 right where people posted silly
nonsense and Elon Musk was bringing it
back I think Elon Musk understands why
Trump made the platform fun and I think
he's confident he can make it fun again
and he kind of is AOC responded and
we'll get into that and some other news
we've got the uh the ministry of Truth
uh congratulations Joe Biden on
launching a government
anti-terror Department of Homeland
Security quote unquote disinformation
governance board being run by a woman
who sews disinformation but isn't that
on purpose purpose you know here's
people are all acting like we're
supposed to believe that this
disinformation governance board is
opposed to disinformation imagine if I
opened an ice cream store and the goal
was to stop the sale of ice cream like
we're gonna open the ice cream store and
then go around making sure nobody no
what if you start something called the
disinformation governance board it
sounds like you ought to be in control
of all of the disinformation and the
woman running it her name is Nina
jankowicks is uh sewing that Rhonda
Sanders has called this out saying not
on my watch Joe Biden and then the
culture war is lit up again because
everyone's like ooh go to Santa so uh
that should be fun we'll talk about this
it's Friday night we're chilling we're
having a good time joining us to discuss
all this is Nick fritis thank you very
much for having me on appreciate you
want to introduce yourself sure so I'm
currently a member of the Virginia House
of delegates but other than that I'm a
good person all right um so that's good
and then um yeah other than uh doing
that and uh being a husband and father
of three kids and of course all the time
with the beard maintenance most of my
time yeah and then obviously I'm also
the host of making the argument where we
actually try to help people formulate
good arguments and avoid really really
bad ones because conservatives do do
that at times you want to show us that
quote on that mug I'm gonna have to
actually I'm gonna do this so um we do
this thing every Tuesday we do Thomas
Soul Tuesdays and I always end it with
and that's why Thomas soul is a National
Treasure and not allowed to die and so I
present this as my gift of my tribute to
the Tim pool team appreciate it um so
yes thank you there was a vote on my
Instagram on which mug I should bring up
here that's a good one and this one went
overwhelmingly there's this in a Ron
Swanson one a couple others but that one
that went well all right we also got
Sheamus yeah also I could not agree more
on thomasaul he really is incredible I'm
Sheamus I have YouTube channel Freedom
Tunes we upload cartoons every week go
over there check it out like subscribe
hit the notification Bell we'll be
uploading a couple things next week I
think you guys will really love got Ian
crossing over here from Ian
crossland.net what's up Nick good to see
you again man you too always great to
have you around on the show how's the
well we'll get into it on the show I
want to know about how the house of
delegates is going over in Virginia I'm
sure we'll touch on it
and uh we got uh Chris over here on the
right what's going on homie oh hey
what's up yeah I'm pushing buttons
that's me Lydia's out um is Lydia on our
honeymoon I believe she is is that what
is going on I think this was happening
that's what's happening yesterday
congratulations Liz if you guys are out
there so uh we were like hey we could
take the day off or you know not and do
work and Chris is able to fill in so for
today Chris is pushing buttons Chris of
course many people may know is the
chicken tender oh yeah taking care of
chicken City and making all that stuff
work and doing all the code and
basically building the whole thing and
and chicken cities are most second most
successful show so yeah have you seen
the chicken uh chicken City Super chats
uh you know Chris built that that
awesome uh algorithm
he's a genius oh yeah
but for now he's pushing buttons so
let's do this before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support our work as a member of
teamcast.com you get access to our
exclusive members only segments from
this show they go up Monday through
Thursday at 8pm and you're also keeping
our journalists gainfully employed and
they love you all so much because you're
allowing them have jobs but more
importantly it's all about the mission
when you become a member we're going to
do more crazy stuff we're gonna you know
we recently put up a billboard in Times
Square calling out this journalist for
doxing Libs of tick tock we're gonna do
more stuff like that with your support
and we're gonna hire more journalists
we're gonna work on more projects we're
building a new studio and boy are these
cultists salty about it they're just so
angry they're like someone tweeted Tim
pool's building a a cult in West
Virginia and it's like there's a
construction crew building a studio and
putting in microphones like what are you
talking about like we have we have a
house I think it's really funny we're
like how many people live in that house
and I'm like three and they're like oh
really I'm like dude there's like it's a
bunch of desks and computers what do you
think we got we got a studio going on
but I guess it's fair to say you know
it's a house so how about this let's get
started and talk about this first story
because it's Friday the story is stupid
and funny at the same time
we had this tweet from Alexandria
ocasio-cortez who said tired of having
to collectively stress about what
explosion of hate crimes is happening
because some billionaire with an ego
problem unilaterally controls a massive
communication platform and skews it
because Tucker Carlson or Peter Thiel
took him to dinner and made him feel
special to which Elon Musk responded
stop hitting on me I'm really shy and a
blushing Emoji Michael malis you can see
under he says he ratioed her in minutes
and then the response to him was so you
don't know how the ratio Works got it
and she got ratioed so here's here's the
funny thing uh Jack besobic I guess
captured what AOC said I I guess some
people are saying she deleted it AOC
said I was talking about Zuckerberg but
okay I think she deleted it because she
realized she only made it worse yeah to
be fair she was talking about Zuckerberg
you think so she says controls a
platform and was taken out to dinner by
Tucker Carlson or Peter Thiel Zuckerberg
was famously taken out to dinner for
some meeting by conservatives us any
currently controls the platform I just
think it's hilarious that Elon Musk
threw back in her face which she does
because ocasio-cortez famously says stop
hitting on me you're trying to date me I
think it's funny when people criticize
AOC her stands go she's not gonna date
you bro it's like is that your only is
that is that your bit is that your bit
cause okay all right well Elon Musk just
threw the pie back in her face yeah also
is Mark Zuckerberg considered right wing
now oh Mark convincing people to commit
hate crimes what is this will anybody to
the right of Karl Marx is considered oh
no no Karl Marx himself is far right no
he was racist oh true
you have to remember real racism hasn't
been tried yet all right did it the way
Marx wanted it would work oh yes
it's funny how it's you know Russia's
coming out saying that they want to
denautify Europe or something like that
and then you think about the
similarities between the woke cult
critical race identitarianism all this
stuff and it's like yeah I understand
the similarities I don't think they're
the same one's more like I guess Ultra
traditionalist and one's Ultra
Progressive one wanted to destroy the
culture one wanted to restore it but
they were both authoritarians who wanted
government based on race
and so here we go I don't I don't see a
a very large difference between these
two groups
speaking of Karl Marx yeah I know Karl
Marx he was the absolute worst and part
of why he's so interesting is because
when you look at his personal life you
see how unpleasantly poorly conducted it
was and it's just the case that when
people don't want to live properly
they'll try to create philosophies that
justify being a bad person basically and
that's what Marxism is and it's just sad
to see how many people have bought into
it and how much destruction it's caused
there was there was a Paul Johnson wrote
a book called intellectual yes where he
went into the the like the personal
lives of like zaja Rousseau and Karl
Marx and pretty much all these
intellectuals they weren't I mean
predominantly left-wing but he wanted to
say like okay how well have these people
actually lived out their own philosophy
and it was incredible I mean you read
about Jaja Rousseau and the kids that he
fathered immediately threw into some of
the worst orphanages in Paris where they
basically died of like starvation and
neglect and then Karl Marx who always
said within communism right the the last
phase of capitalism is people will
actually pay their employers to work
and that's crazy because that doesn't
really happen except in Karl Marx's
personal life where he actually had a
servant that he didn't really pay and
repeatedly you know I would say raped
but repeatedly had a just had an affair
with right a a you know
so it was great he he actually he
actually had the manifestation of the
last phase of what he said capitalism
would bring about yeah well and this is
why you have to be extremely suspicious
of people who harp on and on about how
they love Humanity in this abstract
sense yes because very often times
they're trying to overcompensate for the
fact that they treat everyone in their
personal life like absolute garbage
which is fundamentally the only way you
really can love humanity is by treating
those around you well instead of
throwing vague platitudes out there
about how much you want world peace and
end poverty Etc somebody posted a photo
of antifa marching and they were like
why wouldn't anyone want to be anti-fun
I'm like are we doing this again he's
saying the same thing again and but I
just what I noticed about the photo was
that the antifa guys were really scrawny
like gaunt like thin and what's wrong
with that Tim these people haven't
lifted a heavy object in their lives no
not all of them so I'm sure some have
there are probably some you know some
guys you know I'm not saying literally
everyone but you look at Angie but they
tend to be they tend to be the where
they call the laptop class they're not
working class they get money from
sitting around complaining on the
internet either for writing writing for
BuzzFeed or something you're really sub
tweeting me here man and I'm just like
well look it's it's one thing if you are
part of the laptop class and you
advocate for the workers and you
recognize the value of hard work and
you're not saying give me free stuff
while I smash your windows yeah it's
another thing when you don't do any work
and then say I'm the workers of the
world that's me you should Unite with me
I'm like dude you don't do work like
marching around and complaining myself
you know sometimes there's an element of
work in there you know we got to fight
for our rights I get that but you ain't
lifting any rocks or building any walls
you're not growing any crops it's
fascinating how little these people
actually know about their whole world
well we're we're not building walls Tim
because we believe in bridges I'm sorry
that you don't that's right now AOC was
a bartender and everybody makes fun of
her for that that was the most
productive thing for Humanity she ever
did was attending bar and you know and
look I'm not saying that pejoratively
I'm saying I I have bartenders and I
know that are really good friends and
they are providing a product or service
through voluntary cooperation within the
marketplace God bless you bartenders do
actual work that's the one thing you
shouldn't smear her for being a
politician is really embarrassing being
a bartender isn't oh I know exactly I
feel horrible about it I I have
voluntarily given bartenders my money
yes in the past right I just think it's
funny that people found the one thing
she was good at to complain about it's
like so she actually had a job she was
doing it she was she was working class
she was providing
um relaxation and entertainment to tired
individuals I think bars are fantastic
why make fun of her for that yeah make
fun of her for being having an economics
degree and not knowing what capitalism
is or you know for tweeting things she
knows what capitalism it's mean that's
what capitalism is she tweeted is when
you're a billionaire actually you can't
be a capitalist if you're not a
billionaire yeah she posts on Instagram
she was like people aren't capitalists
because they don't have billions of
dollars and it's like what that's how
that works so did you Google it yeah I I
look you know to be fair that I can't
blame her these like these colleges are
just garbage oh I one of the biggest
eye-opening events for me was I kind of
went to college late in life I was out
in the military already I was like 30. I
was in an English class this is what
surprised me I was in an English class
at Northern Virginia Community College
and then all of a sudden the professor
pulls out the Communist Manifesto for us
to read because nothing screams English
Literature Like a book written by a
German communist but
um he comes back the week later and asks
the classic what do you think of
capitalism the student raises his hand
and goes well I think capitalism what's
destroying this country and I just had
to stop I'm like look just real quick
can you can you tell me what you think
capitalism is
and he proceeds to go out well
capitalism is this you know this rigid
class-based structure where the people
that I said no no I didn't ask what Karl
Marx's caricature of capitalism is can
you actually give me the definition the
professor looks over and goes well can
you I said yeah it's it's it's a form of
Economics where people have exchange
goods and services voluntarily and and
property rights are are you know
respected okay we can use that I'm like
oh well thank God we can use the
definition of capitalism when we're
discussing capitalism but you're right
that was the point like everyone in that
classroom had a version of capitalism
taught to them but born no resemblance
to what capitalism actually is as an
economics I think that's exactly the
sorry the simple definition is
it's an economic system built upon
private exchange of goods and labor yes
that's it the I think she might be
complaining about that the problem is
actually greed I mean maybe maybe
capitalism unfettered creates
oligarchies of private corporations
which is the problem so you know
unfettered gov of any kind of economic
system is dangerous you always need some
sort of Regulation otherwise people
seize control will attempt to seize
power but I think it's greed that she's
sort of talking about but I mean if you
agreed in a communist system it's it
turns out way worse than greed in a
capitalist system from my experience
again referencing Thomas Soul he used to
always bring this up he's like whenever
we try to explain Greed is the problem
for something Soul likes to come back
and look at okay great go sit on your
couch right now and think really greedy
thoughts and see what happens nothing
right there's there's always an action
that we have to actually look at and
observe to determine how you know what
because Alexandria causa Cortez um
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders some of
the greediest people on the planet if
you actually look at the definition of
greed which is I I want things without
actually having to work for those things
I want to be able to take those things
from an authoritarian standpoint that's
far more greedy than hey I want some
stuff so I'm going to go ahead and
produce a bunch of goods and services
that people will voluntarily exchange
with me on right yeah you know and I
would agree Ian that any system when it
becomes unfettered is going to be
problematic and I think the problem is
they fail to see that these flaws of
human nature are going to exist within
any system so what and like you said
when you have a greedy communist
dictator I think that's a lot more
dangerous than a private individual who
happens to be greedy and often like you
said what they will refer to is greed
isn't always necessarily greedy
sometimes it is like yeah a lot of giant
corporations are extremely greedy a lot
of actors within the market are greedy
but that's a question of the level of
virtue our society has cultivated not
necessarily just the economic system
right because if everyone's greedy then
no one is greedy relatively because it's
relative greed is relative to the system
you've set up get to exist within well
even I don't know if I entirely agree
but even if everyone is greedy I don't
think I don't think any system is going
to work if everyone operating within
that system is vicious like you said
Nick so greed is more the intention but
you're saying it's the outcome that
produces the problem is that stealing
then is she talking about stealing so
here's here's where I go back to right
the question is is again people are
flawed I think we can all agree on that
people are flawed the question is is
does the economic system you have
adopted what does it encourage or what
does it incentivize within a capitalist
system where essentially I have to
protect your property rights and we can
only engage in exchange if it's
voluntarily and theoretically to Mutual
benefit well then now I have a positive
incentive structure so even if I am
really greedy if the way that I actually
get the more money or the more stuff
that I want if the best way for me to do
that is providing as many people as
possible goods and services that they
want that even if I have a negative
intention I have an economic system that
fuels that intention in a positive
outworking if on the other hand I'm
gaining it by taking your stuff through
force and violence well I mean I'm sorry
I don't think that produces better
results so there's a there's another uh
example of this in a certain sense Scott
Pressler he's well known for registering
people to vote and he's also really well
known for cleaning up cities he went to
Baltimore he went to a bunch of cities
and he just cleaned up garbage and it
was funny uh he got a bunch of trump
supporters to go out and clean up
garbage and the communities were like
thank you so much for cleaning up and
making our neighborhood nice and it's no
problem we want to show people we're
here to do the work to make the you know
make our everyone's lives better and
then the media smeared him they were
like he's just doing this to get Trump
votes and I'm like
oh no oh he sure tricked us he went out
and cleaned up a bunch of garbage to
convince us that he was a good person I
mean he did so you know in looking at
aoc's complaints about capitalism it's
like shouldn't the attitude when a big
business is like we're going to make a
billion dollars by curing diseases you'd
be like oh okay now I think the real
criticism is when these companies don't
cure the diseases and when these
companies start to when they say well we
don't want to cure it because these
people are customers and we want to keep
making money off it and the issue is AOC
sees that yeah and says that is all of
capitalism and it's like no that is a
Corruption of the system that we need to
deal with yeah these offshore bank
accounts is another one because you
can't really call it stealing if they
set up a loophole for themselves legally
and then take the money and put it
somewhere where it's not supposed to be
but it is stealing it's just they just
wrote it on paper that I'm this is no
longer considered stealing and then they
do it so you know well people so there
was a tweet from uh Jen Perlman who had
on the show she's Progressive and she
said you know we got to end these tax
loopholes billionaires don't pay their
fair share I said what what do you think
is fair is 55 fair share for
billionaires and she said I think if we
close the loopholes it would be 20 to
like 25 to 35 which is actually lowering
the tax liability for the wealthy but I
think a lot of these people on the left
are actually concerned about the
corruption and manipulation of the tax
system as opposed to how much they're
actually paying and I completely agree
so like maybe if we can have that
argument be like yes figure out a way to
make sure those who are supposed to pay
taxes do pay them and we can lower the
taxes sounds good to me right people
should be committing crimes and people
should have less taxes no no absolutely
I mean yeah there's a lot of
manipulation within the tax code and
like again I sit on the finance
committee we write the tax code for the
Commonwealth of Virginia and there's a
lot of debates in there about tax
credits or subsidization or or things of
that nature and I think there's a very
good argument to be made that no it's
like there's the tax code should be
relatively simple to understand in and
it shouldn't be something where you're
setting up a system where the people of
the best lobbyists get the cutouts
the problem that I have with the whole
fair share argument is because they
never come back and say oh this is what
a fair share is because they don't want
to because they want the argument of the
rich aren't paying their fair share
because now they haven't defined what
that is and they're also ignoring the
fact that the the you know the
wealthiest whatever half of the country
the wealthiest 10 percent of the country
pay the vast vast vast majority of taxes
especially at the federal level there's
no question with all the loopholes with
everything they pay the vast majority of
it and they pay a higher percentage than
what they actually control within the
economy that's just a fact I just gotta
tell people taxes are crazy they're
insane yes seriously insane you know
anybody who runs a business knows
exactly how insane taxes are yeah and a
lot of these leftists are people who
don't run businesses no as soon as you
start your own business look at David
Hogg yeah he tweets like why is it so
hard to start an LLC what's going on
with these regulations like yeah yeah
hey Dave go find a mirror look in it
real hard
but no no I I look he's a young guy and
he didn't know and he got a cold splash
of water in the face I'm not here to rag
on him I'm here to say stand alongside
me brother and let's figure out how to
make this easier for Americans to create
businesses you know the the way I see it
is
if somebody says you know if AOC came to
me and said I think you know I just got
my paycheck and these taxes are insane
I'd be like let's work together on a
solution I'm glad you're finally seeing
the problem we're seeing what can we do
to fix it if somebody is an activist and
they're going off the rails and then
something happens to them where they
start to realize I'm not going to rag on
them I'm gonna be like come over and
have let's let's do this let's fix this
problem yeah well I think fundamentally
the problem is Envy so for all the talk
that the left does about how greed is
destroying our economy in some respects
I would argue that it is I think that an
unvirtuous population is a very
dangerous thing and greed is not the
only Vice that's commonplace in our
culture now I would say that generally
the market economy gives you more of
what the people were already interested
in in the first place so it's going to
Veer off into a negative direction if
you don't have a population that has
positive values uh however 100 and but
but on top of that so I don't think
capitalism is perfect I don't think a
Market's perfect there are certain
regulations I certainly believe in but
at the same time it seems to me as if
other systems like socialism
are literally built atop Vice so while
capitalism can allow for greed to
flourish socialism requires Envy the the
issue is
that these people know
Communism works and it works really
really well
once you've killed everyone who
disagrees with Communism
so you just got to remove that Surplus
population and what happens is you end
up with a very very very tiny tiny
population so you have to kill a lot of
people which is why they've always done
it yeah so if you have because because
humans are not homogeneous because
humans are are diverse with different
ideas
you'll have this big population and some
are going to descend so what are these
these Communists always do kill them all
and hopefully you keep purging The
Descent and you'll keep your rigid
fear-based economy functioning well this
goes back to your this goes back to
James's Point as well I've asked this
question before I'm like all right
you're a socialist so you you you again
capitalism is the private ownership the
means of production distribution through
voluntary exchange socialism is the you
know Collective ownership of the means
of production here's my question you
want to be a socialist in a capitalist
country in the United States of America
you can be you can go get some of your
friends right now you can go get
property you can go share it
collectively you can open up a commune
and not only will I as a raging
capitalist not bother you I will fight
to lower your taxes the only thing I ask
in return is you can't force me to go
with you and you can't force me to
subsidize it that's it and that's not
good enough no so they're free to live
the way they want in this country they
want to require me to do it right this
is what that's what I was Finding funny
because uh Ron Paul said something thing
like this country allows socialism they
they need to just go make their commune
and they'd have it but they don't do it
and it's because they don't actually
want communism they don't actually want
socialism they want your stuff that's
why they say we want to seize the means
of production it's like dude somebody
works really really hard and builds a
farm what happens the Communists seize
the farm because the means of production
and that everybody starves they don't
want to do the work they just want what
you got and they will burn the system
down to get it which brings me to the
next story we have here from the New
York Post editorial board Elon musk's
right the left has gone insane I don't
think we need the New York Post to tell
us that Elon Musk is right about that
but he is now they show this meme from
Elon Musk which we talked about the
other day it's from Colin Wright
and you can see in two you got this
little these little stick stick figures
people in 2008 who are left of center
and stayed where they are became
centrists and by 2021 in that same
position are now considered right wing
this is factually true and correct and
the media is desperate to debunk it so
let's let's have this conversation first
let me just show you some uh some
Snippets The Washington Post immediately
said what Elon musk's polarization graph
gets wrong what do they do they show
Congressional charts about house
caucuses so you're telling me that
because the Democrats March in lockstep
on their policy that means they're not
going far left please let's go down to
how they so there's a couple things
actually point out but I'll come back to
this in a second
here's how they actually map it out
Republicans are far right and the middle
of the road people are center-right the
Democrats have moved somewhat to the
left meaning the center is still a
center but the Republicans have stayed
where they are ah you see the
Republicans have always been far right
the argument from The Washington Post is
that well the Democrats did move far
left but you see the Baseline was always
far right so the Republicans actually
are far right my attitude is we The
Washington Post and other media Outlets
are trying to create this narrative
where they've they've created they've
pinpointed where Democrats moderates and
Republicans are then taking the Overton
window and shifted it so it puts the
conservative in the far right quadrant
and puts them as interests you can get
rid of the the underlying graph and we
can clearly see that Democrats have
shifted far to the left it doesn't
matter what you think of conservatives
let me show you a couple tweets
we have this one from the New York Times
they do a clever they play a clever game
with this one the Republican party has
barely shifted to the right look at this
the Democrats they're what 300 further
left here's the game the median party
shows the Democrats are only Center left
yeah and they used to be far right now
the New York Times can justify the
Republicans are far right and the
Democrats are just Center left so when
we say the Democrats have gone too far
left we're talking about in 2008 Barack
Obama saying he does not believe in gay
marriage and by 2021 Joe Biden says
affirm your children
now you've got schools teaching kids
about and and you've got surgeries on
children so it's like if you want to if
you want to talk about where Obama used
to be and where the Democrats are now
the Republicans are are actually to the
left Republicans are now pro-lgbt yeah
not all of them the Republican party is
absolutely moved to the left that's not
even a question in our cultural culture
overall has moved very swiftly and very
far to the left I can't hear another
analysis completely lacking in
self-awareness from some Lefty about how
being on the left is just the normal
default position and therefore moderate
and everyone to the right of them is far
right it's completely ridiculous I think
everyone anyone who isn't on the far
left recognizes that too and so they're
just speaking to their own Echo Chambers
because I've never heard a conservative
or moderate person say anything along
those lines basically everyone agrees
the left has gone further to the left
and everything else has two so one of
the things they're saying is uh someone
posted this a tweet and they were like
Mitt Romney who was the Presidential
nominee for republicans in 2012 is now
considered on the left of the Republican
party and we nominated Joe Biden the
Republicans have gone far right blah
blah it's like Mitt Romney is not called
a leftist or or a left-leaning person
he's called a rhino and an establishment
shill there's a difference and Joe Biden
who you nominated
said recently to affirm your children
yeah his his the president for which Joe
Biden was vice president under
campaigned against gay marriage well
look with Mitt Romney it's an easy
mistake to make so let me just fill it
out for the audience just because
someone is unbelievably lame doesn't
necessarily mean they're on the left so
it's possible for Mitt Romney to not be
yeah I think it's a a stark
um admission from the left well here's
the other thing that I love right is
that as soon as when they are our
Republican nominee or when the where the
Republican nominee
the left says they're they're racist and
they're bigots and they're horrible
human beings like I'm old enough to
remember Mitt Romney being the worst
yeah you know racist on the planet
and I'm I remember the same thing about
John McQueen John McCain was every
democrat's favorite Republican until he
got the Republican nomination and then
Keith olbermans on the TV going he needs
to suspend his campaign right now and
get the white supremacist under control
within his own party so the bottom line
is is that I don't care who we run right
on the Republicans I don't care who they
run they're always going to be a racist
sexy sexist bigot according to the left
and then whoever we run next they're
like oh gosh I remember the good old
days when it was Mitt Romney right you
see that what was it uh who was have who
was it Michelle Obama somebody was
eating candy with George W bush yeah or
no Ellen well Michelle Obama and George
Bush are also friends she tweeted out
about how he's her partner in crime
something along those lines
I
remember in the 2000s going to this
protests and they would hold up signs of
George W bush with Hitler mustache yeah
now
this is this is hilarious a couple years
ago there was a poll that found
Democrats had a more favorable view of
George W bush than Trump and that their
view of George W bush moved positive
from negative
I'm sorry man y'all have lost the plot
because they don't have principles they
never believed anything they just they
just repeat whatever their television
tells them to
this is correct it's not like they
didn't like George Bush because they had
actual reasons not to like George Bush
there are very good reasons
like very good reasons but that none of
those are why they didn't like him they
didn't like them because they were told
not to and now they're being told to
like them so they go remember the good
old days when Bush was I remember the
good old days of uh the protests against
George W bush and then Barack Obama was
like uh listen here uh I'm gonna be
president and we're going to end these
wars and then it's like I vote for you
sir thank you for your vote no kill
those kids fire the bombs and I was like
wait wait what are you doing it's like
I'm gonna blow up some kids and I was
like President Obama please don't he's
like I'm doing it and then he pressed
the button and blipkids and I was like
you know what man but it's different he
did it with more drone strikes right
right actually automated the process uh
his only Scandal was a tan suit you guys
yeah that's what I've been told well
it's not a scandal that he killed
American citizens without charger trial
specifically the indefinite detention
provision they signed the ndaa I think
every year maybe he should have ripped
that thing apart along with the Patriot
Act that's the energy he came into
office with but dude like do you
genuinely think Barack Obama was opposed
to those I think he was and then
realized he'd get killed by the Deep
state if he did anything about it after
like the third day yeah remember okay
this let's move campaign by Michelle
Obama they got an office it's like all
right we're cutting sugar out of our
diets let's move let's get healthy like
a week couple weeks go by and this is in
Katie Couric's documentary Fed Up which
is great uh and then all of a sudden the
let's move campaign got co-opted by the
sugar industry and became about an
exercise campaign let's work out it
doesn't matter what you eat just keep
eating your sugar let's just let's move
totally Twisted they got Twisted by the
people they surrounded themselves by the
people that he surrounded themselves by
were oligarchs shockingly I mean came
into office and said Abe Lincoln was his
hero when he left office Teddy Roosevelt
was his hero because he realized he
couldn't do what able to did that's
where the energy he had I agree to a
certain extent but it's also possible
that he was lying when he was running
for office wow that was a big lie yeah
it was all lies one of the first things
he did was signed off on the bombing of
a Pakistani Village killing women and
children more to think that he got
Twisted by it I mean how could you get
into that position and not in one day
yeah so before he even got in he was
probably getting groomed he got
Choice Awards good one uh he gets he
gets inaugurated and then he he goes
into office and he's like I want to do
all these uh really great things and
they're like here are the documents and
he opens them up oh I've been
radicalized blow up those kids I got a
couple of daughters it was a few days
into his first term that he authorized
these strikes in villages he was lying
they were all lying they all campaign
and stuff
the one person who didn't lie in my
lifetime was Donald Trump's been pretty
good about it oh yeah
doctor Dr Paul this is the man hold on
hold on I want to clarify the statement
about Trump trump lies about stupid
things related to like his personal life
and like yeah his his his gravitas but
when hands are big and glorious right
when Donald Trump said I want to end
these wars he really really tried no new
Wars he was trying as hard as he could
he said I'm Gonna Keep This Promise he
wanted to build the wall he started
building a wall I'm like okay well that
guy's doing what he said he wanted to do
Barack Obama was like we're gonna end
these War course and then within a few
days he was like I'm blown up kids yeah
well there's a reason the Deep State
tried to unsee Donald Trump and they
didn't have the same effort directed
towards Barack Obama he did everything
they wanted him to the the crate the
crazy thing about Trump because when
Trump first got into the race I'm
thinking to myself you've got to be
kidding me like you have got to be
kidding me there's no way I trust this
guy and what shocked me was when he went
in there is one of the biggest areas
where I thought oh my gosh I can't
believe how great he is was on foreign
policy precisely because I I always
found myself in this weird place where
you got one people over here that's like
let's invade everything right and then
you got another group over here like you
should never go to war for any reason
whatsoever I'm like actually I think
there's actually kind of a good middle
ground here and and Trump really did
take that position where it was
he would kick your ass right but he
wasn't just going to do it arbitrarily I
mean when he had a perfect excuse if he
wanted to escalate with what happened
with Iran and the uh the bombing the
Iraq Embassy
um he had a perfect opportunity to be
able to really double down on that and
the fact that he came back he goes I'm
not going to drone strike somebody and
kill a bunch of innocent people in the
hopes that I'll get a couple bad guys
right because one it's a moral too it's
actually counterproductive on a
practical level and I'm sitting here
going I did if you would have told me
this would have been Donald Trump
talking this much you know Common Sense
on foreign policy five years ago I would
have said you were nuts but he was
well we had a great economy
um covet happened last year of his
presidency he takes some of the blame
for some of what went down because he
was advocating for some of this lockdown
stuff too and then everything got out of
control you give the government an inch
to take a mile uh I think he did a
pretty good job and I think he deserves
another term especially coming up 2024.
I think what we're seeing with the
recession or retraction of the economy
by 1.4 percent I'd call that the death
knell for the Democratic party and now
on top of that let's pull up this next
story
DeSantis takes aim at Biden's new
ministry of Truth during press
conference now here's a guy who's
standing up I don't know if the Santos
will run if Trump runs I think he said
he won't but let's talk about what's
going on Joe Biden's Ministry of Truth
speaking to reporters in Williston The
Descent has started the discussion about
the board by saying he is he honestly
thought it was just a belated April
Fool's joke they're actually going to
create in the Department of Homeland
Security a bureau of disinformation it's
basically a Ministry of Truth what they
want to do is they want to be able to
put out false narratives without people
being able to speak out and fight back
they want to be able to say things like
Russian collusion and perpetuate hoaxes
and have people like us be silenced and
gen saki said that she believes the
intent is to stop disinformation how
does the government stop this
information here's the example I gave
Ian what color is the sky
dark black tonight
depends on what time of day you ask uh
Sheamus what color is the sky I'm taking
his answer what color is this guy I'll
go with blue ah we have two different
correct answers hold on the sky is blue
right aha but at night it's black
ah but it's not really blue during the
day it's just a refraction of sunlight
it's actually black so depending on
which way you're looking it's that's
it's the six and the nine thing where
people are looking both ways the
government can use whatever
justification to claim something is fake
news and then eliminate it they
shouldn't be allowed to do that under
the First Amendment I'm willing to bet
they get sued into Oblivion and this
gets struck down by the Supreme Court oh
I think this I think this goes more back
to what was being discussed before
that's the whole idea of self-century
it's not that they're going to come out
and put you in a gulag right under the
you know Bureau of misinformation what's
going to end up happening is that
there's going to be a strong motivation
for people to not go against whatever
the government line is like you you saw
that nobody nobody put any Twitter
Facebook executive Instagram nobody
putting any of them in jail over covid
information they just did enough threats
to where people self-censored I'm going
to tell you exactly what it will be open
up your ears good friends because let me
predict the future
in one year one year's time we'll be in
the throes of a presidential primary
potentially two if Joe Biden is not
going to be running again he says he is
YouTube will come out and say
any story in the news that goes against
the narrative from the Bureau of
disinformation will be considered fake
news and removed from the platform
because we want to maintain Integrity we
are turning to the experts at the
disinformation governance board to make
sure false narratives spread by Russia
aren't allowed and then we won't be able
to share certain stories because a story
will come out saying Hunter Biden
punched a baby and we'll be like look at
this video but the Bureau of
disinformation will say that's not true
that never happened and then YouTube
will say according to the experts at The
Bureau for disinformation that didn't
happen and you posted fake news so we
took it down just like those experts
from the intelligence agencies who told
us that the Russian or I'm sorry that
the hunter Biden laptop story was just
Russian disinformation you mean the
woman who's literally running the
disinformation governance board from Fox
News Biden's disinformation director
referred to Hunter's laptop as a trump
campaign product and helped push
disinformation by claiming that
intelligence officials said it was a
Russian collusion hoax or something yeah
I mean it's horrific it's exactly what
we can expect from a regime like this
however I do agree with you that the
more serious problem is people tend to
self-censor and so look I'm not the
first to point this out but if we had a
media which was completely bought sold
and controlled by the government we
really wouldn't expect the messaging to
be any different than it currently is
they all hold the one hegemonic
narrative
they're going to Gaslight you and lie to
you and try to shut down any information
of the contrary and even when that
information gets out there which it
happens to from time to time because of
the internet and the fact that we have
widespread access to misinformation we
heard about Hillary Clinton's emails
we're hearing a little bit about what
might be going on behind the scenes at
Twitter project Veritas does a fantastic
job exposing political leaders and
organizations left to sympathetic to and
yet even with that information they just
say that's a Russian disinformation or B
A discredited conspiracy theory or C
you're a bigot if you repeat it and so
people shut up and don't say anything
right and so they don't really need this
ministry of Truth to be honest project
Veritas puts out a video showing a human
being say something malicious or
nefarious and then these fact Checkers
are like it was deceptively edited it's
like but there's a video of them doing
it well the thing that I get really
worried about this we had a um we had a
bill someone brought where they wanted
to they wanted to incorporate a class
within public the public school system
that would help children identify fake
news and misinformation right and me and
my college looking from like this is
like some big brother crap right here oh
no no we're gonna have a list of groups
that will come together and you're
looking at it's like oh it's the
Virginia Education Association the
National Education says I mean it's one
left-wing Group after the next
determining helping these kids
differentiate between true information
and misinformation and that's the part
that scares me because so many of the
issues that we look at right now when
you look at if you have eight hours a
day with a child from the moment they
turn five and enter kindergarten all the
way through middle school high school
and then college and you have
essentially warmed them up to this idea
that oh yeah the government helps you
decide what the misinformation is then
you get to a point where they don't even
see it as censorship anymore this is
just another useful service that my
government has provided on my behalf
yeah and we need to get a bunch of keep
going I'm sorry no is it gonna say that
that's the part that is terrifying to me
because again it's this isn't crazy
conspiratorial stuff anymore when you
actually have them setting up this
department within the Department of
Homeland Security which is designed
protect us through anti-terrorism right
that's the part we know that they are
preparing a narrative where if you have
a couple generations of this people just
start to assume this this is just normal
right yeah absolutely I think part of
the reason they're setting this up is
because they are panicking they say that
people are able to access this
information and so even though they've
repeatedly lied it's possible that
they're starting to get worried that
because they've lost their credibility
people are going to stop believing them
I would also say piggybacking on your
comments about the public school system
the fact that the government is sort of
left alone with everyone's children for
eight hours a day it's such a bizarre
societal shift that we almost never talk
about on the right that people are
expected to have their children educated
by complete strangers crazy that's
completely unprecedented historically
you wouldn't let someone who you didn't
know who you weren't at the very least
aware of their lifestyle choices let
alone someone you might admire enough to
allow them to form the mind of your
child have eight hours alone with them
per day and yet not only do we do so but
it is considered a right for teachers to
be able to have access to your child
children in this way and even have
secret conversations with them about
sexuality but it's disgusting what did
Joe Biden say ing
that's true but what did he what else
did he do oh man I have no in what
schools and kids oh he thinks that it's
the right of the teacher the the your
children he's like when they're here
they're he's talking to teachers when he
says that they're yours I said I
freaking creepy I got a bunch of people
angry because I said I think a lot of
parents don't care about their kids
because they send them off to
institutionalized learning facilities
where they don't know the teachers and
then
just don't even know what their kids are
being told or taught don't that that
seems crazy to me so and maybe it's just
my bias because I was homeschooled when
I was little my mom she very much paid
attention to what we were what we were
learning and stuff like that and
actually helped teach us and then my dad
did as well so maybe I see that like my
my parents cared about what we were
learning and they talked to us
and I look at these parents where it's
like I'm in Florida and my kid goes to
school and I got no idea what's
happening out there yeah why would
imagine if you took your kid went up to
a random house knocked on the door and
said can you watch my kid for the next
eight hours every day for the next 12
years well but random person this is
this is why this is why I go back into
the whole it's the whole social
conditioning of something if if your
parents went to public school and then
you went to public school and now you
have your kids and you send your kids to
public school this is just something you
do there's a certain degree of social
inertia with respect to some of the
decisions we make and we think if it was
good enough for my parents good enough
for me then it's good enough for my kids
without recognizing that no the the
window is shifted a little bit with
respect to what they're talking about to
your kids because your kids might come
home and maybe they'll be able to do the
math that they were supposed to learn
how to do or maybe they'll be able to
understand some of the you know the
science they were supposed to be taught
but they're definitely going to
understand various left-wing concepts of
gender identity yep and whether it was
naive of the people at that time or
whether there was some legitimate reason
they believed that the public school
teachers who were going to be left alone
with their children or their children
were going to be left alone with had
values that were roughly similar to
their own so they weren't going to have
to worry about their child's mind being
malformed in some serious way but of
course that's not something that you can
never trust strangers to not do and Tim
you mentioned that people wouldn't go to
a stranger and say here have my kid for
eight hours today it's even worse than
that it's that stranger coming to you
and saying you have to give me your
child for eight hours it is my right
that's disgusting I heard consumerism
defined in a very interesting way a
couple years ago and it was basically
that it is the act of Outsourcing more
and more things from the household and
there are a lot of things that it does
make sense to Outsource but then there
are certain things that it's very
strange to do that with and I would say
the education and formation of your
children is one of them and yet we've
done it in the most like cynical
capitalistic assembly line sort of way
that would make even the most
the sociopathic Robber Baron blush and
it's completely championed by the left
back in the day I'm talking about a
thousand years ago or thereabouts if you
had the money you could send your kid to
be educated in Venice Italy buy the most
intelligent Scholars of the time that
was your choice
maybe they would the king would come and
say your kid's coming with me
a Swiss boarding school as well yeah
Swiss boarding school you get sent to it
was like you know prestigious if you
knew the people they were gonna go study
with and you wanted them to learn that
kind of thing that's understandable but
today we have the option as humans now
in the United States we have the option
of where to send our kids so we it but
to like you said to give that up to the
higher power I think is lazy well and I
do think we've been indoctrinated today
there there are well wealthy parents you
know people who know what's going on are
finding ways to keep their kids away
from these schools it's the regular
Working Class People who can't afford it
because you know you look at some what
the rich families do the ones who can
afford it at least they'll find private
schools they'll talk about it or they'll
send their High School age daughters off
to Switzerland to a swim boarding school
well again there's there's nothing
there's nothing wrong like again going
back to the whole capitalist thing
capitalism also about specialization and
division of labor we're all good at
different things and we find worth it so
I I'm not we homeschool our three kids
right and my oldest is my oldest is 19.
so she's gone through the whole process
my I have a 16 year old son 14 year old
daughter and and here's what we found
it wasn't that we just completely said
all right Tina and I will be the only
ones educating our children at any point
no we we had co-ops that we went to we
had other things I mean my son and I
took a blacksmithing course together so
there was all kinds of ways that we
could reach out into our community and
find people that could educate our
children on things that were either you
know cool and unique and in line with
what they wanted to do or was something
that we couldn't do because bottom line
you get past fifth grade math I'm done
man I got I got nothing for you at this
point I don't know Google it so we we
still have those resources we can find
the difference was is that when one of
my child was struggling with something
we could find the resource that would
help them and when one of my child was
excelling with something they were able
to go as far and fast as they possibly
could none of them had to sit there and
wait for 28 other kids right or none of
them had to deal with some of the I love
the socialization like oh okay
socialization my kids go to you know
educational events they go to political
events they go to sporting events they
go to community events so they get
plenty of socialization as homeschoolers
now yeah you're right they don't go to
an institution every year where every
once in a while they'll walk in on two
kids having sex in a middle school
bathroom so they don't get that
socialization
right but that's the sort of thing
that's going on and this idea that it's
either you have to be responsible for
every aspect of your child's education
or you send them to a government school
that's that's a false dichotomy it's not
an either or proposition I agree but I
also want to make another Point here so
you mentioned that there are a number of
ways that you actually can Outsource
homeschooling and I agree that's
obviously very important but clearly
you're vetting the people out who you
end up leaving your child alone with and
that is the important difference between
a homeschool Co-op and a public school I
want to go back to uh this woman the the
ministry of Truth we have this tweet
from Christina Pasha oh you can say I
retweeted it she says Biden's minister
of Truth Force away lock us down this is
what we want we want to be criticizing
this lady is the definition of unwell
she's supposed to be this disinformation
person you know executive director
whatever the government says whatever
the authority says is true that's her
attitude she tweeted long story short I
think we as a country might be too um
free-spirited to put it diplomatically
to come comply with social distancing
recommendations unless they're forced
upon us so Force away lock us down
people are not taking this seriously wow
now that was from March and that was
still a rather extreme position
Americans are too free spirit remember
when found she said it's time to shut up
and do as you're told yeah yeah these
people are nuts well it blows my mind
because she was saying this in 2020
right yeah so she was saying this again
under the Trump Administration
because I used I used to have this
Theory where it's like okay you know
leftists think they're always going to
be in power and when they're in power
they want all these new Government
powers and authorities and and whatnot
because they trust their own people to
do it but one of these days they're
going to get somebody that they
recognize oh this is the problem because
I don't want I don't want this guy
having this much power
and and I've come to the realization
that they seem to like it
yeah masochism I mean it's just well
this idea of of government Authority and
power and somebody telling them what to
do and what the right answer is and I
again I always thought that clearly
they're going to understand at some
level I don't want everyone anyone to
have that's present to have this power
and I'm I'm starting to think that's not
true and it's crazy to me well I would
disagree to some extent I hear what
you're saying but I think the reason
that they support it is because all the
people forcing their worldview on
everyone else who has any level of power
right now is on the left and so what
they appreciate is the fact that people
who would not obey them are being forced
to by the state and so ultimately
because as soon as you have someone like
Elon Musk come in and who is you know
potentially going to be the owner of
Twitter here and simply says I'm just
not gonna bully the people you want me
to bully they completely lose their
minds so it's not so much that they like
having decisions made for them though I
think there's an element of that there I
think they love making decisions for you
they're they're the the most conforming
anti-conformist well not not only did
you tweet this authoritarian nonsense
she has several tweets like that she's
also outright spread disinformation
herself where she said the hunter Biden
laptop story was Trump a product of the
Trump campaign things like that so are
we are we really supposed to assume that
they have the the best intentions no no
no I think as I stated earlier if you
create a store called like swords and
things I would assume you're selling
those things I would not assume you're
trying to stop those things from being
sold so when they create the
disinformation governance board and put
a woman in charge of it who so is this
information I think the purpose is
entirely clear just lying to us about
what they're trying to sell to the
American people
she must have a bunch of self-hatred
because when she's saying force me it
locked me down
um that's really disgusting and
masochistic of like self-hate type of
thing yeah I know some people are into
it you know maybe she's like yeah but
you know Daddy government not to the
maybe yeah but that's masochistic to
have this kind of psychopath psychopathy
and in power is is devastating she also
said this jackpotobic has his tweet in
2020 she said that the executive branch
shouldn't have the power to determine
what is fake news she then goes on to
say that it's fake news that Facebook
has a bias against conservatives and
then adds she's she's funded by Facebook
so uh sure she was uh right in the first
point the federal government I'm sorry
the executive branch shouldn't have the
authority to determine what's fake news
now she quite literally works for the
Department of Homeland Security under
Joe Biden determining what is fake news
brilliant quite amazing but this is to
my point that they're fine it's just a
product that I'm wanting to force their
worldview on other people right I mean
so when it's a trump Administration no
the government doesn't have the ability
to determine what's true or what's false
but as soon as Biden's in office I mean
it's unsurprising right it feels like
Nazi Germany man like 1932 when they set
up that that board of what is a Ministry
of it was Goebbels go balls pardon me
yeah the propaganda again I the the
thing that blows my mind about all of
this is that there's this overwhelming
faith in government power in order to
achieve certain positive ends and again
going back to Thomas Soul because I do
that regularly
it's this whole idea if the government
doesn't deal in Solutions the government
deals in trade-offs but if you've if
you've built in your mind that really
what this is about is government
wielding power to compel people to do
the right thing and really this is just
a question of getting the right people
in the position to be able to wield that
sort of authority well then this kind of
makes sense if you understand that
people are fallible therefore the people
in political power are fallible then
you're a lot more cautious about them
having this kind of authoritarian power
over things and and it is amazing to me
that we are not that far away from when
you had legitimately you know we still
do have violent Communist governments
that are suppressing speech suppressing
their own populations and doing so
through propaganda government-controlled
propaganda and to think this is an okay
idea and then it's coming from the left
right the very people that used to like
Stick It To The Man are you kidding me
well let's uh I'm gonna do something
else right now I am going to defend this
woman not because of this video Jack
besobic tweeted out meet the Biden DHS
National head of censorship please do
not retweet this video as it may upset
your new internet overlords I don't
really want to play this do I have to
play it's really gross but yeah probably
I'm gonna play it guys I'm really sorry
you have to hear this one all right but
we're going to play don't play at all
though
atrocious
ah it hurts she put that on Tick Tock
that CCP Tech she put that on Tick Tock
and I you know I saw this video I did
say I was gonna Defender and I will but
when I saw this video I thought to
myself
I think there's something about
left-leaning Millennials where they
never grew up the world is Harry Potter
yeah Voldemort's the you know everyone's
Voldemort and they post these videos on
Tick Tock as if they're children
like I'm sorry ma'am you're in your late
30s and you're heading up a government
institution and you're singing Mary
Poppins
I just I feel like these people are
children
yeah I mean they reject adulthood they
reject responsibility ultimately and I
think that's well I think that's a lot
of where the the gender Insanity comes
from is well part of becoming an adult
is being firmly rooted in either your
masculinity and your femininity and if
you're called to marriage starting a
family having children but they
completely reject that responsibility
and so they start to reject the concept
of gender altogether I'm gonna defend
this woman because my point is that or
not gender sexuality you're allowed to
have nonsense to him you're allowed to
have fun and do fun things and have
hobbies if you're older and you like
skateboarding perhaps some people are
like you're too old for that no you're
it's good exercise maybe you like
playing Magic the Gathering hey hobbies
are fantastic fun ways to exercise your
mind or your body I got no issue you
want to sing songs that's great but in
your job as a disinformation expert
singing about this weird stuff you're
starting to get a little weird with it
but here's where where I will defend her
Jack besobic tweeted this out and I
think he should not have we you know
we're good friends with Jack but I think
he should not have posted this it's he
wrote he wrote I saw it you have to see
it and it's a video apparently of this
woman in college with another woman
I did not mean to play that it is not
good it didn't sound bad it is not good
okay
um it's it's D plus material C minus
maybe but I'm not here to make fun of a
woman who was in college and wrote a
song with her friend and just filmed it
put it on the internet I think that's
fine she did if I saw if this video came
out today and it was on Tick Tock I'd be
like hey keep it up guys you know keep
keep working hard keep practicing keep
writing one day you're gonna hit that
number one you know I would encourage
young people to do good stuff we also
have this one
from The Daily Caller flashback video of
Biden's minister of Truth singing about
effing her way to fame and power The
Vibes are horrendous no no no this is
stupid she's she she's making a point in
the song she's singing I want to play it
because it's actually you you might not
like it but she is good at what she is
doing in the song she's talking about
how she's talented and works hard but
isn't notable or famous it's a bit it's
a musical she then says who do I have to
F to get Fame and power the bit is that
in Hollywood that's how you do it she's
making fun of Hollywood and everyone
laughs I'm gonna play a little bit of
her singing Just so you can hear
[Music]
she's actually really good it doesn't
surprise me like a theater actor to be
the propaganda art Minister absolutely
someone who knows how to do that
performance what bugs me about this is
they took the one thing she's good at
and then plastered on the internet she's
okay she's not even that good she's
singing from her chest she needs to sing
from her core she's gesticulating her
posture is really bad her shoulders are
all hunched like she could be a lot
better she's sure 78 good and she's
going to fact check everything you said
yeah I am I am not here together I'm not
here to give her a Tony I'm just here to
point out that she's singing well people
are enjoying it they're having a good
time she's probably cool personally but
doesn't mean she's not inside I know I
don't think she's a misinformed I think
she's nuts but why would you highlight
something that is like a positive about
her to try and own her like when they
showed AOC dancing on the rooftop and
they're like look at her and I'm like a
college student having fun am I supposed
to like you think that makes her look
not cool it makes her look personal
right I think there's something I think
there's something of a generational
difference here too with respect to what
what one generation tends to think is
this is something that discredits a
person versus what a younger generation
thinks discredits a person so I think
some of this is is a is a misread of you
know how you're going to influence your
audience with respect to how to think
about her so like I I see this I'm like
she's actually a pretty good singer like
this doesn't this doesn't strike me as
oh well gosh that's why I have a problem
with her it's not because she's the
authoritarian Czar of the government
disinformation you know I think that's
exactly so yeah yeah also with the AOC
thing so much of that was manufactured I
don't think I knew anyone who was upset
about her dancing because I don't live
in the film Footloose do you know a
single conservative who is genuinely mad
at her for dancing I don't think it was
is the majority but there were people on
Twitter who were constantly making fun
of her for it well that's true okay
there was one thing that was done with
that whole thing that I did think was
funny and that was they showed her
dancing and then the thing said when
you're first in line for the breadline
that makes funny because she's you know
she's a socialist and make memes out of
it for sure yeah absolutely and I'm you
know I think that's fantastic but I
didn't know anyone who was genuinely
upset like oh she danced this this clip
from The Daily Caller and I think the
clip jackpotovic pointed out it's like
guys you're reaching dude yeah but that
first one wasn't reaching where she's
like Rudy Julie is a political political
politics crap she was spreading
misinformation in that little cutie Mary
Poppins song she was singing and that
was directly relevant to the job she is
now going to be that was more exactly
and real quick I think people saw that
and criticized it which was warranted
and then grabbed other stuff of her
singing as if it was bad that she sang
yeah no no no no yeah also I mean we
understand the concepts of information
and misinformation differently than the
left does and that is to say we
understand these Concepts correctly
because we understand that the purpose
of information is to help a person form
their worldview so that they can know
the truth the left sees information the
value of information is anything that
helps them Reach the end of bringing
their political worldview to fruition
and so to them misinformation means
anything that gets in the way of the
social order I'm seeking to establish
which is why they were constantly saying
that they were trying to crack down on
misinformation even though the things
they labeled as misinformation were then
revealed to be true and they never
walked their policies back I just want
to point out I think it's funny like you
know that we're all here like this lady
spreading dangerous disinformation and
then Ian's like she's she's singing from
the chest so her shoulders are crunched
up she wants to get better she's getting
to the heart of the problem he'll be
better no I think I'm just saying
you took theater yeah so you're seeing
it from a different angle from us where
ours is purely political and he's
looking at her performance like no no
her shoulders it's like relax your
shoulders you know let your head fall
back and your keep your chin low and so
to your point I I think this is we were
having this debate a while back um and
it was the whole idea of post-modernism
and deconstructionism was the idea of
what is the philosophy which informs the
left and the way they think about these
things so when you've accepted that
there is no such thing as absolute truth
whether it be moral or just you know
factual and this is all a question of
power structure and it's all a question
of which group is going to dominate the
power structure in order to help their
group or their tribe or whatever it is
you're absolutely right misinformation
is no longer this idea of what is
actually true because there is no
objective truth there's just power
struggles and right now they want their
they want their group to be on top and
the way that you do that is by
controlling the flow of information and
they honestly believe it's going to
produce positive results for the people
that they care about right so it's it's
not as if they've they have purely
nefarious I mean we would consider it
nefarious because we think it's rooted
in a lie but they can actually convince
themselves I'm doing a good and Noble
thing on behalf of marginalized
populations and anything that stands in
the way of achieving that for your
so-called truth is irrelevant of it yeah
this is also sometimes known as the
problem of moral licensing so this idea
that because I'm a good person with good
motives anything that I want to do is
acceptable in order to achieve that goal
and of course what always ends up
happening when you hold that position is
you just become a bad person and then
the fruits of your endeavors tend to be
horrible as well guys yeah I think I
know what we need to do uh-oh we need to
get Nina jankowicz cast in a Broadway
musical we need to allow her to take her
talents and run with it Ian stop
criticizing her abilities no no because
you remember what happened last time an
art student dropped out oh my gosh
wow did they make 1984 I'll never give
up on you Nina
Ian won't struck you he will teach you
how to sing there was another out of
Broadway
no one believed
was criticized for it is that really
what it was that was a big part he had a
hard time drawing the human form that is
fascinating yeah that is fascinating
well yeah and just that an authoritarian
despot who murdered people failed to see
individuals as what they were was that
before the World War One his trench
warfare in World War One or after as far
as like getting when he got rejected
from art yeah oh that was I'm pretty
sure that was after World War one but I
don't know I think I think you started
before but I'm just waiting for medium
matters to write oh yeah Tim pool
Compares Nina to Hitler because she
sings
compare the disinformation board to the
Nazis disinformation board but that's
about it I haven't done anything except
for that cringe musical yeah I have I
have to admit when that first like press
release came out described me what it
was like I I as I'm reading it I'm
hearing it in a German accent amount
like the Department of Homeland Security
misinformation
public statements this is stuff they've
been doing anyway behind the scenes now
they're just codifying it somebody
somebody super chatted saying Twitter
was their disinformation government
board yeah yep and how he bought it so
they're like all right just do it to the
government
clearly we cannot rely on the private
sector to do this properly we have to
step in for ourselves you have to crack
a few likes if you want some omelette
how do you stop a government like our
government from doing stuff like that
like we're supposed to vote the right
people in so that they stop it from the
inside what was your answer lawsuit I
think they're going to get I think the
government's going to get sued on on
First Amendment grounds and the
disinformation board will be disbanded
overnight it can't last the the first
step is always you know vote for the
right people right theoretically if the
right people are running second is
um yeah you sue the government you
actually use the the separation of
powers in order to do it and the third
one is is you know it's the passive
resistance right it's the peaceful
resistance it's government it's like I'm
not going to comply with this let's see
how much you really want to enforce it
yeah they'll go to like um Twitter's
board or they'll go to the developers
and give them a gag order and say give
me your code give me your login info and
the people be like well if I don't then
the feds are going to come raid my house
and put me in a prison for a year
without seeing anyone so they do it but
if a way to pass simply resist that is
to get rid of the centralized services
so you as a tech company don't control
the login data or the password data it's
encrypted and unavailable you ever see
Sheamus there's that South Park episode
where they're imagining George Lucas and
Steven Spielberg ruining Indiana Jones
no I don't I don't know so it's like
didn't already do that with the fourth
one yeah they did there's a scene where
it's like I think it's like deliverance
and there's two you know like redneck
guys and they're like you look mad at
good and they like take Indiana Jones
and they'd go at them and I was just
thinking like based off what you were
saying about income tax and stuff it'd
be funny to do that scene but it's the
government taking your income tax like
hey there boy that income's looking
mounted good it's like no stay away
federal government oh I'm coming yeah
well the income tax is another one of
these things that's just part of the
status quo now so people don't
understand how unbelievably insane it is
especially at its current rates the idea
that just working and being productive
results in you being penalized by the
government taking your wealth from you I
would love to have an expert on the show
to go deep on the history of income tax
it got started with 1913 are you
familiar so it's technically technically
it actually started under Lincoln
was the first person to actually level
like a federal income tax and was
ordered to pay for the Civil War but
yeah did it become like truly
constitutional the way we have now until
you actually passed the uh 16 16th
Amendment yeah Sixth Amendment of the
Constitution it was fascinating because
the original debate was all right we're
gonna we're gonna do this right but it's
only going to affect this portion of the
population and we're going to cap it at
three percent and you actually have
people going wait I thought you said one
percent you can't you can't put it at
three percent if you put it three
percent they'll actually take all three
percent and now I'm I'm way wrong on 14.
16th income tax 14 is the one they're
trying to get Marjorie Taylor green on
yeah dude did you see her talk to uh
what's his name the the reporter yeah
Costa he was trailing her and kept
asking and she's like just pull up the
text you're talking about read it out
loud right now and he did and it
basically shows exactly what she was
saying is true that she was like
questioning martial law
misinformation is any information that
is bad for the regime or used against
the regime so right now if uh you mow
someone's lawn for 10 bucks you gotta
then when you see that 10 bucks you got
to give the government depending on your
tax bracket between like 27 or 37 maybe
even more and that's just for the income
tax now if you're running a business
you've got to split the employment tax
is going to be 7.5 on the business end
7.5 on the person's end and so that
typically goes in with the income tax
but now that now you're running a
business right you get 10 bucks the
business takes the ten dollars you then
say okay now what do I do I'm gonna pay
myself because I'm the employee of my
business so I Gotta Give 27 to the
government then I got to give the
business has to give 7.5 percent to the
government so now you're actually at you
know about 36 or you know what are we
looking at 35 percent then you've got uh
then you take that money say okay great
now I'm gonna buy the fuel I need for my
lawnmower and then when you go and buy
that fuel you got to give the government
another cut for the for the sales tax
and the gas tax
you see it just it just it's going to be
it's going to be taxed on every single
level at a certain point like if you
basically if you want to make four
dollars you have to make ten dollars
right every every aspect of monetary
exchange is taxed and that's just too
much so it's really difficult to have an
argument with a Libertarian when they're
like taxation is theft and I'm like well
technically at this well now it is yeah
like you you want if you come to me and
you say that taxation makes sense in
these certain contexts where it's like
the roads everyone loves that argument
I'm like well look I think taxation
is fine maybe maybe the income tax is
not but certain taxation I have no issue
with to a certain degree like the
founding fathers even said taxation but
we should have representation we're at
the point now where it's like literally
everything you do is taxed now they want
to tax how many miles you drove on your
car it's like dude I already bought the
card I bought the gas the gas was
already taxed for how much I was going
to drive now I'm going to tax my car by
the odometer now if I sell the car got
to pay another tax but I bought I got to
pay a tax if I get the money I gotta pay
tax everything you do then you die they
tax you again well I I love the the
whenever they make this stupid argument
that I can't believe that Warren Buffett
pays less in taxes than his secretary
bull crap all right he pays a much
higher income tax rate the difference is
the capital gains versus there shouldn't
be a capital gains I mean it's a form of
double taxation so I I got my money
through income I then pay taxes on that
income I then take some of what's left
over and I reinvest it into something
that helps somebody else start a
business or hire more people or expand
their operation in the hopes that maybe
one day I will actually receive a profit
from selling this and then you're going
to tax it again
and now it's at a slightly lower rate
and so that's when they come up with
this justification and it's just crazy
to me because ultimately what we're
doing is we're disincentivizing
productivity right yeah gambling Tech's
actually the stupidest one people don't
realize that when you wager one dollar
so say you put you put 10 bucks down on
uh on roulette you say 10 10 bucks on
red
you win 10 bucks you owe the government
two dollars and eighty cents so you're
wagering ten dollars for a chance to win
less than ten dollars like there's a tax
on all of those winnings and then uh you
can't you can't claim losses on more
than you've gambled so if you walk in
with 100 bucks and lose it that's too
bad you can't claim it claim a loss on
that unless you're a professional
Gambler yeah so also like when you look
at Biden's policies in his proposed
policies with respect to capital gain
tax one way he plans on taxing the rich
quote unquote is to have everyone who
makes more than a million dollars have
their capital gains tax increase from 20
to 40 and the idea is well that's only
going to hurt rich people but obviously
if you are a wealthy person you are not
going to bet 100 of your own money to
only potentially keep 60 of the winnings
because that's an idiotic move to make
and so small businesses
and that need investment from wealthier
people just aren't going to end up being
formed if that policy ever takes effect
well and do you know what they're going
to do it's like they're always going to
accept invest they're always going to
exempt if you buy government bonds so if
you want to give the money if you want
to give your money to the government and
get a guaranteed three percent interest
or whatnot oh yeah sure you can do that
all day long they'll make all kinds of
exceptions for that but if you actually
want to invest in a private Enterprise
well now all of a sudden we want to we
want to tax the hell out of you and this
unrealized gains is the biggest
nonsense it's literally money that you
haven't made there's no such thing as an
unrealized that's why it's called
unrealized it's it's literally they are
taxing something you don't have I'd like
to pull up this story we have here from
The Daily Mail GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
claims Biden's plan to forgive ten
thousand thousand student loans is to
distract from his failing agenda and
stunt to subsidize degrees of the elite
and leave working Americans paying the
tab for all of my Progressive friends
who are sitting here saying I don't
understand why anyone would be opposed
to forgiving student loan debt don't you
want to make people's lives better
you're just saying you're to suffer
because you suffered let me explain
something very simply what I'm saying is
that I do not believe the government
should take from the poor to give to the
higher income earners low income earners
will be paying the sub paying the taxes
that subsidize High income earners
getting their debt cleared and the high
income earners who have the debt got to
spend that money and do things with it
now I am for student debt forgiveness I
say we tax the universities and seize
the endowments and forgive all the
student loans that way but if you're
going to tell me that you are a reverse
Robin Hood who wants to steal from the
poor to give to the rich I'm gonna say
screw off yeah also whenever someone
says something like I can't imagine why
anyone would oppose for giving student
loan debts like why would you admit that
you're telling you're telling on
yourself dude that's really embarrassing
it's actually not that hard to figure
out because it's a regressive tax people
who get degrees actually do tend to make
more money in the idea that someone who
a already paid their college off because
they worked through college or already
paid their debt off or decided to start
working in a trade should be on the hook
for the money that someone else who's
making more money than them voluntarily
took on his debt is insane well I got I
got to ask like do you believe that the
government should forgive student loan
debt I said I don't think it can like
what do you mean of course it can no no
it can't there's no way when you say
forgive what you're essentially saying
is that the person that lend somebody
who is now saying you don't owe it back
that's not how the government did this
the government took tax dollars by force
and then distributed in the form of
loans which you voluntarily took so the
government can't forgive that all they
can do is transfer the responsibility
for paying it onto somebody that didn't
take out the loan right so that's all
that's happened this should never be
talked about can the government forgive
student loan debits should the
government transfer student loan debt
off of people that took the loan and on
to people who didn't take the loan
because that's what they're going to do
so I could forget the interest I guess
what if they seize the endowments from
the universities or tax the universities
to pay back those loans I mean I I the
bottom line is that legally the the
universities were in a position to be
able to you know again the money went to
the person the student and the student
chose which university that they went to
so as much as I think the university has
totally been in bed with the government
in order to make all this happen right I
still don't think you could I still
don't think you have legal grounds to go
and seize their property as a result of
this it as much as I would look at it
from kind of a cosmic moral sense and be
like well that you know karma's a you
know well I think the universities are
corrupt I think the the loan situation
is predatory and I think you get out you
get it look we want Millennials buying
houses and having families many of them
are settled with debt because they were
told to get these loans out and they
weren't smart enough to figure out why
they shouldn't have got that and so I'm
like okay if you want student loan
forgiveness then you got to take it from
those universities that got that money
these are the universities that went to
these students and said you have to do
this what are you going to do unless
they have these they have these um
recruiters at universities who go and
tell you why you need to go there how
much it'll cost then these people go and
get these government-backed loans now
they're in debt okay the system can eat
itself there you go problem solved oh
look from a Karma perspective yes from a
legal perspective I don't see how you do
it the people that are the people that
are truly the most responsible for this
or the politicians that advocated for it
because they're the ones they're the
ones that actually cast the little vote
they push the little button saying yes
we should make this a portion of the
budget there's a way to do it without
um taking any money from anybody and
that's just terminating interest on all
loans so you got to pay back the
principal if you borrowed 40 000 from
somebody and you spent forty thousand
you got to pay it back but the interest
rates which are compounding we just
delete those gone because those
interests weren't weren't granted to you
that's just them saying Oh it's been 10
years so now we say you owe us another
50 000 and it's like well that 50 000
didn't come from any we're just saying I
owe it to you we can get rid of that I
mean the government shouldn't be in the
business of doing these sorts of loans
anyway and that's an incredibly
impopular thing to say and it is
absolutely 100 true because we've
created especially since most of the
universities are are either
public-private Partnerships or they're
state-run universities so again this is
this is the government subsidizing
another government agency in order to
push a particular agenda and then it
works out perfect for politicians
because they can then they can first
approve the loans with no intention of
you ever having to fully pay them back
and then come back and say I'm the nice
guy that's going to forgive this when
they know damn well they can't forgive
it they can only transfer it on other
taxpayers yeah well and the real Scandal
is that so many people feel they need a
college education in order to make a
living and also that in a number of
circumstances that can actually be the
case we need to ask ourselves if a
person cannot have a well-paying job
with a four-year degree which actually
isn't true but less just say we're the
case
then why is that and why aren't we
trying to solve the problem of the first
12 years of education that everyone has
provided for free not preparing them for
the marketplace now of course it's
because public school is a rack and it's
a horrible system they don't really have
your child's best interest in mind but a
parent who is homeschooling their child
obviously has the best interest of their
child in mind and they're going to
ensure that their child is educated in a
way that will prepare them for the
workforce so they can be a productive
adult
I think it's sad that people think they
need college yeah there's trades there's
entrepreneurial uh entrepreneurship well
I mean it's you listen to Elon Musk talk
about this you listen to like garyvee
talking about it so it's the same thing
it's like our schools are not designed
to actually do anything to help out with
entrepreneurial ship it's designed to
make the best version is designed to
make very good Factory workers the worst
version it's designed to make really
good conscripts
and and the problem that I have with all
of it is what did you expect right you
you have the government running an
institution where they don't actually
have to be responsive to the end users
of the customers of the product or the
service that they're providing because
every time we try to pass any sort of
legislation they're even doing something
like hey dollars follow students oh my
gosh you hate public school and you hate
public teachers or public school
teachers like no or I just recognize
that like everywhere else in the
marketplace when people have genuine
choices and they can go and find the
services that work best for them you
actually get better quality at lower
prices and more accessibility yeah when
you think about a voucher system for
schools so I think there's a couple
different ways you can do it I think the
idea of dollars following students
whether you want to call that a voucher
whether you want to make it an education
savings account I think it would be a
vast Improvement on what we currently
have what's funny is that the left
immediately comes back and goes you
can't spend public tax dollars for a
private service provider Oh you mean
like with WIC or EBT or road
construction or jet fighter construction
or I don't know lodging and per diem the
politicians at private yeah Section 8
housing like we do it all the time it's
like you know you don't want it here
because you want politicians to actually
control the education of my child and I
don't understand why because half the
time I'm hearing we need to get politics
out of the classroom I know a way to do
it actually give poor parents an
opportunity to be able to do what Rich
liberals do with their kids and send
them to private school I I can't tell
you how funny it is when I will talk to
some liberal and say they say
Republicans are Banning math and history
and I say Well they're banning Praxis
they're banning they're banning critical
rights Praxis the practice of these
theories and they say yeah but that's
important context in history and I was
like dude if you want ideologies in
schools we can start with the Bible
because if you think your ideology
should be there why could a teacher
teach any ideology they wanted how about
if you don't want religion in public
schools we then say you can't have other
ideological practices in those schools
all the same or or we just do this right
I don't want to tell the person that has
an EBT card you're only allowed to shop
at the government grocery store I've
assigned you based off of your address
there wouldn't be any food there so how
about how about how about we do this you
want your kid to learn that you really
think that's the best learning outcome
for your kid okay I might I might
disagree
but I am not going to use the power of
the state to compel you to educate your
child the way I think is best I'm going
to let you make that decision
and if public dollars are following you
can come up with some okay hey they got
to take one test a year or there's got
to be some criteria like you can't take
them to a school that's teaching them
you know violence against other people
whatever that's fine
but you educate your child in the way
you think is best I will do the same
this goes right back to the whole
socialism point I made earlier it's not
good enough for them that they be free
to do what they want they must compel me
to do what they want I make no such
requirement of them so which one of us
which ideology is the peaceful tolerant
one that actually appreciates diversity
that's the problem is the right has been
tolerant and peaceful and the left then
took over the institutions while they
were being tolerant and peaceful well
yeah I mean the right is is obsessed
with human respect in being perceived is
one of the good ones by their enemies
which is completely suicidal and stupid
I'll also add that whenever you have
these left Wingers who fire back at you
for supporting vouchers by saying you
hate Public Schools they are admitting
that parents would send their children
anywhere else but public school if they
had the option according to Angelus
makes that point beautifully daily on
Twitter like oh he's fantastic why would
the money go away from public schools if
there's an option they're so good aren't
those Public Schools incredible aren't
they good for kids but at bottom
what they're saying is okay yes parents
would choose to send their kids
elsewhere but we can't allow them to
have that choice because I decide how
other people's children get educated not
them it's there's some value to that to
to having um uniformity in education in
that like math for instance if one
school teaches the kids two plus two
equals five because it's 2.4 plus 2.4 is
then and then the other half of the
schools teach two plus two plus four and
then all these people come out of the
schooling systems and they can't agree
on basic ideas like math then we're in a
really improv like a challenging social
place so so two parts of that one you're
starting to see that now within the
public school system exactly they're
doing it they're the ones going two plus
two equals four is racist right the
other thing I would say is this how many
parents are going to send their kids to
a school right within a Marketplace of
Education opportunity how many parents
are going to send their kids to the
school that's teaching them two plus two
equal five maybe some would do we think
it's going to be a major already do we
think it's going to be enough to
actually cause a problem if that if that
is such a concern with education why is
it not the same concern with respect to
food or with respect to where you buy
your vehicle or with respect to where
you buy your health care because quite
frankly all of those are really
important decisions as well and here's
what we find is that within the
marketplace when people have options the
the best way to ensure quality
is by giving people choice not by
putting a government board in charge of
it right like I don't want the
government misinformation board deciding
what math looks like because they're
probably not going to come up with good
ones so yeah in a perfect world it would
be great if everyone you know
could learn math the same way they don't
right so being able to have different
options for students hopefully to come
to the you know a logical and rational
conclusion at the end of it but the idea
that the government taking over that
process is more likely to get us a good
product I don't I don't see it I mean
we've seen the exact opposite right
every year since the Department of
Education was founded test results have
have absolutely not improved but
fundings a funding adjusted for
inflation has improved and so I think to
your point yeah we really didn't see
this kind of bizarre two plus two equals
five thinking creep between the public
schools until long after the government
had complete control over them and
frankly if you were to go back to a time
where schooling was more a product of
the community and someone walked into
the Little Red Schoolhouse and said hey
let's teach our kids two plus two is
five they'd get laughed out of the room
no one would be willing to do it you see
Thomas Massey's proposal yes the
Department of Education will will
terminate on December 31st 2020 or
whatever yeah that's just one sentence
the best troll move he ever made and I
love Thomas Massey the best troll movie
ever did though is when Betsy DeVos was
put in charge of Department of Education
of the Trump Administration Massey put
out this massive thing going do you
really want this woman in charge of your
child's education support HB you know
and it was the same thing right right
and he had all these lefties retweeting
him so yeah we need to get behind this
bill because I don't want Betsy DeVos in
charge but that was he was making a
solid Point you're right you don't want
this person to charge your child's
education so let's get rid of the
mechanism that they use to try to
control it and put you back in charge
well so one point that the right and
that Libertarians will make when we're
arguing with the left is
you guys should want to abolish this
particular State institution because it
might be the case that eventually
someone who's more sympathetic to our
views will be in charge of it as opposed
to someone who's sympathetic to your
worldview the reason I think that
criticism never works and won't work and
won't persuade them is because as a
conservative or as a more right-leaning
person a more traditionally minded
person you know that on the local level
your Solutions are generally things that
most people support and would be willing
to buy into and I think the left knows
that in order to get their agenda across
they need a gigantic bureaucratic State
that's forcing these things onto
everyone so the risk of a conservative
being periodically in charge of it is
worth it to them because the only way
they can have any success is if it's
forced onto everyone from some
institution of that sort I think that's
right I I think they've I think they've
realized that you know the old adage
camera what it was that you know
conservatives come in and end up
conserving things that the Liberals did
20 years earlier yep um and you saw that
within the UK with the National Health
Service right now now there's not a
single Conservative candidate that's
going to run on the idea of like they
looked at has been a colossal failure on
a nuttinberg levels maybe we need to
privatize more no it's always put us in
charge of it and we'll we'll run it more
efficiently and more effectively and so
yeah I think they I think they've made
the the deal here and they realize that
the more bureaucracy they get eventually
they push the Overton window in the
direction they want and they end up
controlling it I want to jump to a
totally unrelated story because it's
Friday and we haven't talked about this
all week Alec Baldwin could go to prison
criminal charge is still possible in
Rust shooting Sheriff says and I just
want to highlight that Alec Baldwin my
understanding is that he told the police
he knows the difference between dummy
rounds and live rounds but that he did
not check the gun himself
we then saw the footage that got
released because everyone was wondering
like hey they filmed Alec Baldwin doing
this where's the footage and you can see
that elephant lied he said my finger was
not on the trigger and you can see in
this footage they released his fingers
on the trigger every time that doesn't
mean his fingers on the trigger the time
he actually fired it but come on if I'm
gonna have to make a bet his finger was
on the trigger here's the best part
about all this
when out when people point out that Alec
Baldwin Jack masobic said this he's like
Alec Baldwin should not be talking to
these cops without lawyers because he
basically admitted to doing it people
are like yeah but he's an actor this is
what I hear from every single person on
the left for some reason wanted to
defend Alec Baldwin he was on set doing
what he's supposed to do it's not his
fault
please pull up the manslaughter
provision and I think what was it New
Mexico
show me where it says actors get a
special exemption from involuntary
manslaughter
it doesn't exist if you are handed a gun
and you pointed at a person and you pull
the hammer back of a single action
revolver and it fires that's involuntary
manslaughter textbook yeah also what an
unbelievably stupid excuse like you know
if someone's filming you and you point a
gun at someone and pull the trigger I
guess it can't be prosecuted because
you're an actor I'm making a movie could
you imagine there's like a serial killer
and he's got a camera guy with him the
whole time he's like he's making a movie
She's filming a prank show or they go
around and stab people to death and it
was a prank bro so so just for fun I'm
gonna go against every Instinct I have
and I'm gonna I'm gonna argue the other
side of this
so you're in a position where you're
handed a gun and that gun is supposed to
be loaded with with blanks for the scene
because obviously sorry dummies because
they want to be you know loaded with
live rounds uh there's no reasonable
expectation that would be loaded with
live rounds
um and this is a scene that you've done
this is something you've done before and
so you do it this time and this time oh
my gosh there's a live round in it
and that's where it goes into the
involuntary manslaughter point it's like
okay you've got obviously we're not
talking about you know necessarily like
premeditated murder or you know anything
like that
um
I I can there's a part of me that can
understand like okay I I this is a part
of my job this is what I do this is how
it works and I did it this way and
something tragic happened I'm more
concerned about again how did a live
round get into that and then why did why
did she get even with a dummy round
because here's the other here's the
other part that I think a lot of people
don't understand about this is they
think oh I'm firing a blank
okay well there's there's differences
between fire and a blank I mean there
have been Hollywood stars that have died
because of a blank because of the
wadding yeah was it uh Brandon Lee
Brandon Lee and that other guy in the
80s who pointed the blank to his head
and killed himself yeah and they just
they don't understand how some of this
works now Alec Baldwin's been doing this
for a while 40 years and he should
understand how it works and that's the
part where a little bit more culpability
for me creeps into this I don't care uh
Who You Are
if you are handed a gun
and then you point it at somebody and
kill them you're in trouble no there's a
question so Alec Baldwin trying to use
this actor excuse where it's like well
someone else was handling the gun I
don't care and people are like I tweeted
about this and they're like here's
someone who's never been on set before
and I'm like dude all you're telling me
is that the people on set are idiots
yeah they are they were in that movie um
Gutierrez read Hannah the the arm what
was she the Hannah Gutierrez read yeah
she's the basically not the arms Master
but in charge of the weapons she's not
the one that handed the gun to Alec I'm
pretty sure she wasn't even on set
there's video of her from the day if you
guys haven't seen this video it's all
over the place now there's all this
video right after the shooting and she's
like they tell them they tell Hannah
that that Alec 511 she's like Alec
Baldwin Alec Baldwin had the gun yeah oh
my God and like she had no idea what was
going on someone basically in my
estimation there were a bunch of people
that quit walked off the set they said
it's unsafe someone loaded that gun
knowing that Alec was gonna pull it out
not check because he's a lazy whatever
and that's exactly what happened I think
someone put that in there so that he
would do the killing let me clarify
something I'm not saying that he's not
criminally liable what I'm saying is is
that when I first heard about this I'm
like okay an actor did something stupid
with a gun not a shock
um it is there is there any sort of
reasonable from a legal perspective is
there any sort of reasonable argument to
be made that hey I I was supposed to get
a gun to do this I was supposed to point
and put and pull the trigger and do this
I did that and then something happened
that I did not intend now the other side
of this is going back to your point
someone hands you a gun the way I grew
up that what I was taught is you are now
responsible for everything that gun does
and you don't get to say well this
person handed it to me that's the part
where the culpability creeps back in
every every time I've done an ex like a
handoff for any weapon the same thing
occurs the magazine is taken out you
clear it make sure there's nothing in it
then you lock the bolt back the hammer
or whatever and then you hand it pointed
down you follow all the rules and I
don't even consider myself a gun expert
I just have guns so I'm like it's not
even an issue of
proper protocol it's like I'm not I'm
gonna I'm gonna check my firearms and
I'm going to make sure it's clearly
visible that there's nothing in it I'm
handing it to you and it will still be
treated as if it's loaded even with the
magazine removed Alec Baldwin when they
when they're on movie sets and people
are acting like it's normal to be handed
a weapon that's that's sealed
potentially loaded and you're gonna be
like I trust them the weapon from the
people on set I'm told if they're
supposed to open it show you the rounds
take them out explain what they are put
them back close it and then hand it to
you with all safety protocols happening
before your eyes yeah Alec Baldwin was
supposed to go through that check then
have the weapon and that's why he would
not open the weapon up and check Alec
Baldwin claimed he's like if I were to
open it up and mess with it they would
stop the shoot because that would be
tampering with a weapon and I'm allowed
to do it only the armorer is yes but the
armor is supposed to go up to you show
you the mechanism show you the safety
take it open it up let you know they'll
take out the magazine clear it and say
everything's here it's it's unloaded
I've showed it to you now you're
responsible for it they didn't do that
so Alec Baldwin received a weapon did
not check he's responsible oh no he's
checked and I would also argue that the
person that was responsible for doing
that so for instance if if someone
handed him a weapon and said here's your
weapon for the Senate he did it he's
still responsible because he didn't
follow the protocol they're also
responsible because they didn't follow
the protocol I don't know
so this this assistant director I guess
is the guy who handed him the gun but
they're on set he's he's got a gun he
says it's for Alec it's not his job to
check it that's true so I don't actually
know if that guy would have any
responsibility the responsibility is if
Alec Baldwin knows he's receiving a
weapon that guy isn't the one who
pointed it and pulled the trigger no no
that I'm not arguing with that yeah
that's yeah so Alec Baldwin involuntary
manslaughter prison he's also the
producer of the movie so there's another
layer that adds a culpability he should
have been overseeing the safety
mechanisms the armor should have been
there if they're handling live when we
used when I was on live rounds when I
was in the military we we would we would
go to the range we do our thing then
we'd also go to like what we call shoot
houses
and within our shoot houses we're
practicing Close Quarters battle so
you're doing high intensity explosives
um you know hostage rescue the whole
deal you'd go from you'd do live rounds
at some point you'd also do what we call
Sim rounds so some rounds had a
different barrel for your your M4 and
your M9 and they fired paint rounds you
would shoot each other with the paint
rounds now again you weren't shooting a
live round through those Sim barrels but
we went through so many checks and
processes when you were when you were
transitioning from I've been doing some
rounds to live rounds right you did so
many processes to do that and and if you
screwed up it was on you because at the
end of the day you're still responsible
for what's going on at that range I mean
you could you can point to a range
safety officer and they might get in
trouble as well but ultimately you're
still responsible for what happens with
the firearm in your hands
yeah that's the way it's got to be
moving forward unless you're an actor
well yeah no you're still responsible as
an actor no I know you killed that woman
man Vladimir Putin's filming a movie
no in Ukraine is that why he's there
right now yeah he was filming a movie
with Russian troops right the troops
just it's it's it's it's set crew man
it's all for the energy also I'll set
crew they're just there to uh film a war
flick and uh all of the civilians and
all destruction well I mean I feel like
I can't blame potent it's a movie with
Alec it's not even that I hate the guy I
just feel like justice has to be served
it'd be the same if it was my brother
that did it
yeah
what's that
if it had been my brother in his
position and he killed somebody I'd same
thing he's got to serve Justice like
that you can't just let people get away
with that or they're going to do it
again and again you got to stop it in
its tracks yeah everyone's been
predicting that he's gonna pay some
settlement to the family and nothing's
gonna happen
probably wow why should he get in
trouble because he killed somebody well
I know that but I mean like in their
mind they're thinking like well you know
I love the conspiracies theory the
conspiracy theories though that the
woman was like an investigative reporter
and they whenever something weird
happens you get the conspiracy there's
your tied all into like this Grand
Hollywood conspiracy careful that it's
not like an Alex Jones uh what do they
call it Sandy Hook thing where someone's
like she's a this and that then the
family comes after you with try with a
civil suit yeah I don't talk crap about
people when they're dead no you
shouldn't talk crap about private
citizens with things that aren't true
especially when there's emotional
emotions involved like death the truth
shall set you free you know Alex Jones's
issue is that he said things that
weren't true about private individuals
that had been killed that was a big part
of it was the families he was talking
about he was making fun of people who
are still alive I'm making fun of he was
making statements about them so I just I
just say
um you know in these in these
circumstances
you know he always wanted to have the
truth you always want to have your facts
he also shot a dude in the shoulder he
he killed a girl and then wounded
another guy oh that's the the director
you watch the video it's crazy
he's I don't know man it's crazy someone
set him up that is nasty I I don't I
don't know if I agree all those people
that hated him on that set and then all
of a sudden there's a oh my bullet shows
up in the gun he's using like and maybe
he put it there maybe maybe but I didn't
seem realistic I just think that you
have to make assumptions to assume it
wasn't him
yeah I do you're right there's no way to
know it's the simpler solution albeit
sounds crazy that Alec put the bullet in
there
wow either way it's an assumption Alex
was holding a gun and the gun went off
and killed someone from the only that's
the only thing we need to know where the
bullet came from as far as I'm concerned
Alec Baldwin is responsible when you see
his finger on the trigger when he's
pulling the gun in practice in rehearsal
he's got his finger on the trigger and
then he's like my finger wasn't on the
trigger like dude he's lying trigger and
the crazy thing too is
one of the reasons I actually think what
we're seeing now lends to the idea that
Alec is guilty of just outright homicide
is that the way he was holding it
he could have shot himself
no I think he knew it was in that gun
he was it was it was in his it was in
his chest hole a holster you pointed out
you can't assume you don't shouldn't
assume well the thing I was the thing
was there's three things that detective
looks for on this it's right method
um motive and opportunity so we we
obviously know that we know the
opportunity I don't know what the motive
is the motive was that the crew was was
yelling at him and fighting with him and
it was stated uh this is Viva fry did a
really good job breaking this down that
Hutchins was aggravating was very
aggressive with Alec that she wasn't
supposed to be directing him she was a
cinematographer Alec had already
explained that he was frustrated we know
he's he's temperamental we know that the
staff on the set have been complaining
and threatening to walk off he's been
dealing with the whole time and now he
gets this woman who's bossing him around
he's pissed off
he had a motive there's another guy on
the set they interviewed and he's like I
don't want to I don't want to throw
anyone under the bus but let's just say
the practices on that set were not
safe and it's like he's basically what
he's saying is they're they're shooting
live rounds for fun on set but he didn't
come out and say that he didn't name
names but it's like he was a guy working
on the movie basically saying they
weren't following safety protocol all
right we're gonna go to Super Chat so if
you haven't already smash that like
button and subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends if you
haven't already we do those special
members only shows Monday through
Thursday at 8 p.m and I always say that
8 p.m at 11 p.m I don't know I did that
the show starts at 8pm that's why I say
that but for now we will just read some
of your super chats so get those super
chats in and let's see what you got all
right we got paid sin says Isaac botkin
from T-Rex arms would be awesome to have
on the show discussing 2A and the wins
they're getting in Tennessee oh yeah
what's going on in Tennessee well they
got constitutional carry that was the
new thing right oh that I mean happening
everywhere oh my gosh right I carry that
bill like every year in Virginia
Virginia's not interested or what it we
can't get it through the Senate like I'm
I'm actually the chair of Public Safety
Committee one which is where all the gun
legislation goes is the first year I've
actually been the chair of that
subcommittee and I love it
um but yeah we can't we can't get it
through the Senate at this point
so uh that just basically means people
in Virginia got to go vote for some new
state tenders and yes they get that
constitutional carry out there
and then maybe one day we can just cross
our fingers that constitutional carry
makes its way to the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court says Nationwide
constitutional carry sorry Maryland
all right Murph Tri says breaking news
Elon Musk buys McDonald's the
corporation is rumored to be destroying
evidence of why the ice cream machine is
always down do you see what Elon tweeted
yeah he's not a magician he's like I
can't work miracles guys I can't do
Miracles that was really really good
all right and that says Tim please read
Nick scored a perfect score on vcdl gun
bills I'm from VA and would love to meet
you Nick perfect score I did where's
that perfect storm yeah it means I had
100 score with respect to protecting our
Second Amendment right that's right
thank you like um conflict of interest
for you to suggest people that you think
should be in the Senate no not at all
that's awesome not at all uh yeah
that's easy
all right
Roberto Lara says the ministry of truth
will be absolutely effective as gun free
zones
that's right
warwolf says happy Friday to the crew of
shimcast IRL it is once again graphene
Friday Ian please enlighten us your
faithful and beautiful fans with a
graphene fun fact and Tim please make
official timcast beanies and then a
bunch of gorillas
uh they actually discovered graphene by
peeling Scotch tape off of graphite I
think it was in early 2000s and they
want a Nobel Prize for that I also
rolled a 73. oh there's a big number Ian
I'm appreciate I you know I really
appreciate that they shouted us out here
on shimcast I don't know what those Tim
cast beanies they were talking about at
the end are though I don't know you know
what do we won't sell tim cast beans
we'll only sell shrimp yes beanies
and they'll be green and they'll have a
gold buckle this is very offensive they
come with Lucky Charms
yeah I'm leaving
Sheamus literally puts an Ireland behind
him and he's from Chicago there was a
fan who gave that to me and I thought it
was very well crafted I wasn't gonna not
put it there beautiful well how how uh
how many generations back was your
family in Ireland it was a while ago man
it was a while ago they came over it was
great grandparents and then they all
just stayed in neighborhoods on the
south side of Chicago where Irish people
were and good pizza that's why yeah
exactly that's why they stayed the Irish
or uh connoisseur is a fine cuisine as
you know pizzas specifically they're
like look at that first they were like
oh look at the pizza originated and by
the time my parents came around like
look at this beach at Eric's great
this one's about five inches deep don't
you wow look how much cheese is on that
huh it's a lot of cheese there I think
someone's cooking a deep dish Giordano's
right now right now you can smell it
well I'm gonna eat it I'll tell you that
much I can't smell it but I will taste
it we'll see because every so often I'll
go downstairs and someone will have made
a deep dish pizza because I order I love
ordering pizza and hot dogs from Chicago
it's true yeah me too and they're good
when we get Portillo's here
it's really really funny because of the
conspiracy theory when they're like
Obama ordered oh that's pizza right he's
from Chicago
so Portillo's famous Chicago hot dogs
and then Giordano's of course from
Chicago Pizza I also like Lou Malnati's
but I'll order it they overnight you put
in the freezer and then everybody makes
it and it's it's really good if if you
like pizza
Giordano's is a bucket of cheese it's
it's straight up it's a bucket it's a
bucket made of bread with cheese and
sauce in it and it's delicious it's like
just take a bag of mozzarella put it on
a plate put tomato sauce on it microwave
it and you got a Giordano's Pizza it's
like doing a shot of alcohol you do the
shot but it takes like 10 or 20 minutes
to start to feel it at least for me
sometimes but it's same with the pizza
you take a big bite of it you eat one of
those slices and it's like 10 or 20
minutes before you feel full no it's
like also you can get two in really fast
if you move but yeah
just eat this and now I'm lactose
intolerant look at that it's like what
an inch of cheese it's something like
that it's thick yeah it's huge you know
what that is that's America right there
that's right because we can yes I mean
it's weird because when you're in
Chicago you don't really eat it all that
often no no I mean something you do to
remember it's a tourist thing I think I
ate six slices of it a couple weeks ago
but it took me four or five days to get
it out of my system oh yeah
yeah well all that cheese and the bread
too the bread was delicious all right
Nathaniel sacrinty says did Elon buying
Twitter cause the Overton window to
shift dramatically causing everyone to
start seeing what's been hidden for so
long it could be what's causing so many
people to be labeled the right wing now
I mean it just happened last this week
but I do think Elon buying Twitter
shifted the Overton window dramatically
and I love how it's like a different
country now like the Overton Windows
dude he doesn't even like own it yet
yeah Seth Rogen comes out he's like I'm
pro-life I've always been
well it's funny but it just goes to show
you how the American people actually
feel about things as soon as they're
just like gently tapped yeah in the
specific Direction they go there it's
like yeah no people are on the right
it's like it's almost as if when you
stifle speech and tell everyone that
they have to Parrot the left-wing
narrative as soon as they get an
opportunity to just like let that spring
out and go to the right they do oh
there's there was a lot of lefties on
Twitter that realized that not everyone
thinks they're wonderful and witty and
beautiful as soon as that algorithm
isn't doing the heavy lifting form dude
I know the the former administration at
Twitter was like that weird parent who
pays people to be friends with their kid
and their kid is just horrible to them
and the parent stops paying them
what's going on like why don't why don't
you like me it's like because you're
terrible you've always been terrible to
everybody you mean I'm not beloved all
right Busy Bee says I am a three-time
felon all from 08 to 10. today I
petitioned the court in VA the state I
got in trouble I am proud to say I now
have all my rights back including the
Second Amendment so happy glad to hear
it I do not I do not like the idea that
someone gets a felony for any reason
they can't have guns I think you pay
your debt to society you should get your
rights back but I I do agree people said
you can lose your rights to due process
that is true
all right the one free man says not
saying Elon is Batman but has anyone
ever seen Elon and Batman in the same
room together
uh I have actually Christian Bale and
Elon wrote a party once oh no uh has
anyone seen Iron Man and Elon in the
same room together
I want I think Iron Man's a better Iron
Man's a better analogy or more analog
analogous to uh Elon because Batman was
Peak Peak Human Condition yeah Batman
exercised and trained with assassins and
then uses well for gadgets Iron Man was
a wealthy industrialist who made a
powerful suit yeah and he wasn't like
physically trained or anything so he
learns more like Iron Man plus
considering how uh Iron Man's character
is and Elon strolling yeah definitely
all right
Sean St George says have any of you
heard of the Indian folk metal band
bloody wood their track gadar has some
of the best political lyrics I've heard
quote I see a state turning to Faith
Faith turn to hate hate turned to vote
votes turn into notes as an example
interesting
foreign
if you woke up in a hospital from a
10-year long coma red Washington Post
while watching SNL you'd think you'd
have brain damage and ask to be
unplugged that's actually that's a very
good point I almost want to steal that
for a cartoon I won't I'm too was it
zooby who's that I'm just a regular
person from 2012 yes yes but also yeah
no but it's a great Point can you
imagine someone who woke up from a coma
10 years ago looking at the paper and
going I can't believe how far right this
country's gotten yeah that's exactly the
conclusion it's unbelievable yeah this
is a far right Nation if someone from
2008 was in a coma and woke up in 2016
they would be like the Republicans have
gone far left yeah they'd be like the
Republican nominee is unfurling a pride
flag on stage at the RNC what's happened
to my country but Obama I know wait
oppose gay marriage and Hillary Clinton
opposed gay marriage in 2016. now this
is the funniest thing the leaked emails
that came out from Wikileaks show that
Hillary Clinton my understanding of the
reporting opposed gay marriage had said
something about it and Donald Trump was
was for it he was like guys it's done
we're not going to win this one how is
it that the Republicans were to the left
of the Democratic candidate on that
issue that's Trump was uh was a liberal
yeah yeah that's true
I think it was mostly a populist right
yeah
says Tim remember when Trump campaigned
on universal Reciprocity for concealed
firearm licenses Pepperidge farmer
members that was his biggest lie I
didn't know that but if he didn't get it
done then that's too bad we'll call him
out for it maybe uh we'll make him
uphold that in uh term two but did you
did you know that is that something
Trump promised the universal reciprocity
for concealed carry uh I don't remember
I honestly don't remember on that one
what we need is for the Supreme Court
right now to weigh in on constitutional
carry so so here's the here's the
interesting Dynamic on that one
um and and here's the crazy part because
that is something that legally could
happen now now before a liberal
interpretation of the 14th amendment I
don't think it could have because the
second amendment was originally a
Prohibition on federal power not on
state power
what was interesting is that when the
liberal interpretation of the
establishment Doctrine essentially said
that well no the Bill of Rights applies
to all of the states
then all right then I guess the
sacramentum plays well no no we didn't
mean the Second Amendment no yo that's
what it means and so it's interesting
because once upon a time you could have
made a good constitutional argument that
the Second Amendment is only a
Prohibition on federal power but you
can't do that if you're going to accept
right you know substantive due process
everything else right right all right
Ben says I was in Middle School when
Obama was elected Michelle made school
lunches so bad it was incredible from
three or four options in grade school to
one or sometimes two inedible meal
choices
we used to have this thing when I was in
grade school called a super donut
and it was so good yeah what was it it
was a donut and they would but super but
they would it was in like a piece of
plastic and they would heat it up oh
yeah I never got really excited when
they had Super Donuts another problem
with schools you know what maybe
Michelle needed to do something maybe we
needed that the hospitals too that they
served such junk in hospital we had can
we just have cookout Burger take over we
had uh we had gray and blue hot dogs
dude oh yeah yeah yeah did you guys ever
have those oh yeah kind of like that
like some of that like big pot of
boiling water and whatnot there would be
like gray or grayish blue yeah and
people would just be like what is this
is that because they sat out for a while
no I have no idea just I don't know if
I've ever ate one of those though
yeah gross yep unacceptable
all right let's read some more
Trevor Cameron says the sky is opaque
daylight retracts through our
nitrogen-rich atmosphere making it blue
and at night we see the stars through an
opaque Sky uh we'll see what jaina has
to say about I think that's not true
yeah they refract through nitrogen-rich
atmosphere but uh I don't believe opaque
is the word you are looking for well I'm
certainly not going to listen to it
until the department of information from
the Department of Public security
with that logic nothing is any color
because you're only seeing the bouncing
light off of the thing you're not
actually looking at the thing I learned
from The Young Turks that the sky at
night is actually pinholes punched
through so that the light of Heaven can
come through
something people used to say
is that an argument that was made I'm
not sure like at some point I mean or
something
I don't know like there's that is what's
happening that is what the sky is yeah
the vibration is vibrating the Higgs
field and when it hits a certain
frequency cracks open as light
so maybe there's the pin holes you're
talking about there was there's a rant
from Jank where he's like yelling about
religion and he's like these people
think the sky at night was pinholes
punched out so that the light of Heaven
would shine through well it's like well
yeah that was that was the that was the
biggest invented it was the big push in
uh 2007 to teach that in public schools
don't you guys remember when the
religious rights said let's teach kids
you know what's actually happening but
like you know what's actually happening
weird sexually perverted teachers try
and have secret conversations with
children about sexuality like that's a
real thing that's happening instead of
jinx weird imaginary persecution complex
fueled ideas about the religious right
well the only reason you're concerned
about that is because you hate gay
people that's right you're right
man getting right to the center of it I
love when people know what I'm thinking
better than I do so that they can tell
me because it's always a surprise a
public school that's what it's all about
I think it's more funny that someone's
like I would like it if teachers weren't
having secret conversations with my kids
about sex and they went why do you hate
gay people it's like how can you take
this from them what are you what are you
implying about gay people yeah yeah it's
just it's what I can't stand about you
know people have said the trans agenda
or the gay agenda and I'm like dude Dave
Rubin opposes this he's gay yeah right
there there are many gay people who are
like that's wrong and then there are
many trans people who are like it's
wrong it's a bunch of weirdo cultists
who believe weirdo things I don't know
if there's many trans people that say
it's wrong because I don't know that
there's many trans people a pretty small
community there it is a small community
but I just mean like there are prominent
individuals I'm being facetious as well
but I think when we've talked about this
it's more or less how those groups
operate as a political force rather than
what every individual identifies with it
I also find it a little bit
contradictory that like the same hyper
crunchy the college educated mom that
will not feed her child in oreo because
it has chemicals in it is saying like
but here's some puberty blockers and
maybe we cut some things off yeah if you
feel like you know wearing high heels
today like I think that's that's a
little bit contradictory nylon heinek
says to quote Sydney Watson govern Me
Harder daddy that's a good one
all right Agamemnon agamemnon's gym bag
says saw a penalty wow my sonian quote
right now I'm gonna take Troy saw a
panel on Fox making fun of her and
saying that she isn't the person for the
position the person in the position is
is just a distraction we need to fight
the creation of a Ministry of Truth
absolutely Dragon Lady says I was in a
discussion about Liberty and lockouts on
Facebook when somebody said Americans
are too addicted to Liberty he got a lot
of agreement they were lefties did you
guess addicted to Liberty what's the
alternative should we just like live in
concrete blocks where Big Brother tells
us what to do and when to do it yes
obviously Tim that's the whole thing you
have to obey whatever the left I mean
we're not saying that you should live in
concrete blocks and listen to Big
Brother but if the science says that's
what you should if we decide at some
point down the line we just want to make
sure you are going to listen wait did
science say that science hasn't spoken
much lately I get I get nervous when
science doesn't show up you guys you
actually play science says yeah science
has been out of the news cycle for some
time yeah science let's play science
says oh science didn't say that that's a
good one actually I'm just gonna go home
and uh care for my family not pay
attention the media science didn't say
that's a freedom tune thank you you know
it will be yeah science I I want to do
one called fauci says but then he you
know he fell out I want to I wanted I
wanted something nice for all the
leftists who might find themselves
watching this show you know you may be
sad you may be scared because you
haven't heard from the science in some
time well we can't get you the signs but
we can't get you the next best thing
don't worry just put on a couple of
masks and Rand Paul will go away
now that wasn't perfect but I'm sure
many people it calmed you down you got
your little fix there that was good
sewer of accents that was pretty damn
good Rand Paul
he has that he talks funny right
he does I would say think's funny too
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Cerro says 13 income tax that's
adorable currently in our 40 band here
in the UK not even our top wow yeah it
sucks to be ruled by a king 13. 13 is
for what though like if you're no 13 is
13 the lowest bracket it's right or no
what's the lowest bracket for people who
are popular they pay nothing don't they
no so you you have when you take into
account this is this is interesting when
you take into account government
transfers which is not just what I pay
in taxes but what I get back to
different government programs and what
you have to make almost 75 000 a year
before you are a net taxpayer at the
federal level well this is what people
people don't understand is that if
somebody who makes 50 Grand per year
ends up paying 20 grand or 18 in taxes
they're actually getting a tax benefit
of like 25 to 30. in all of the services
that are provided to them so but not
even in services like like earned income
credit child credits oh yeah yeah people
don't understand that the overwhelming
majority of tax revenue comes from the
wealthy and that subsidizes the poor so
poor people actually don't pay their
fair share relative to what they're
getting in return well we we had an
interesting we had an interesting case
this last time in the general assembly
where somebody got up and said you know
these people pay a higher percentage of
their income than these people over here
here's the problem she wasn't taken into
account all the transfer payments so
she's saying someone's making twenty
thousand dollars a year is paying this
much in taxes and that's a higher
percentage when you include the transfer
payments that person is getting
right it drastically changes it but if
you don't take the transfer payments
into consideration she can come you can
give her everything she wants and year
after year she should come back and say
these people are paying a higher
percentage because you're not actually
counting the transfer payment what are
the transfer payments it's like so you
pay taxes right and then somebody
collects maybe EBT or WIC or they get
rental assistance or something like that
that's a transfer that money went from
you and your taxes to this person over
here because of the income bracket
they're at but they never count it as
part of their income so as far as the
way they do the measurement on who's
paying a larger person with unemployment
right I pay a tax then with from that
tax they give someone their unemployment
insurance but then they have to pay a
tax on that yeah unemployment insurance
so it's double taxed let's say it costs
you know 100 bucks to send a firefighter
out to your house that's that comes out
of your taxes right except for somebody
who makes no money let's say someone's
unemployed they get those services for
free now I don't have an issue with that
firefighters I think should be like the
the the issue back in the day was that
you can't have a firefighter show up to
a block full of houses and be like that
one doesn't get our service and the
other house is then set on fire so they
that we needed to find a way to deal
with that but that means that people who
are paying almost no income tax are
getting the equivalent of 100 bucks for
free well that 100 bucks has to come
from somewhere so that means a wealthier
person has to pay the equivalent of a
thousand dollars for you to get your
fire Services you see and so uh the
roads are probably a better example when
the government fixes the roads
the the amount of money that a rich
person has to pay towards the roads is
going to end up being millions of
dollars whereas a poor person it's going
to be pennies military too I think yeah
military is the stuff that we don't I'm
not a big fan of but I think people do
overestimate how much we spend what
percentage of our tax revenue goes to
outright like military weapons and stuff
like that but most of ours I mean we
spend like I think around five percent
of our GDP with respect to military
spending when you actually look at what
the government is spending and what they
have discretion over versus what is like
settled like Social Security Medicaid
Medicare that dollar that comes off the
top before you ever get to the
discretionary spending and so that's why
you'll see sometimes the left going like
oh my gosh the military is 27 of them
but no it isn't it's it's five percent
of the overall budget It's a larger
percent of discretionary because you've
already done all these programs that are
eating up as a huge portion of your
budget so instead of getting the money
back they'll just buy more bombs and
blow them up more
with the military yeah as discretionary
funds rather than giving back to the
people they'll spend it on purpose no
the discretion even even within the
discretionary most of that is going to
funds outside of Defense we have a good
one here from Mike Dipietro he says the
university should have to co-sign
student loans goodbye worthless degrees
hello first class liberal education
imagine what that would be like agreed
yeah let's let's at least do that you
got to co-sign if you want someone to
come to your University and you're
guaranteeing that this degree is going
to be right for you then assume the
responsibility on that loan all of a
sudden these these degrees like you know
feminist interpretive dance gone
just gone fact check true as long as
you're not giving the money directly to
the students to spend how they want
that's what they do I know that's the
problem because default on the coast
sign
oh yeah well the universities aren't
going to co-sign they'll learn their
lesson quick huh
well it used to be if you wanted to get
a loan for college you went to a private
lending institution and a private
limited institution would ask questions
like how'd you do in high school and oh
by the way what are you going to study
because they wanted to make sure that
you were going to study something that
could get you a job that would allow you
to pay back the loan politicians don't
care they can just forgive the loan and
then be heroes on both ends of the
spectrum
all right Eric Lakey says I'm an
electrician and make good money didn't
take any loans to get where I'm at sorry
I am not responsible for paying for
gender studies Majors depart Major's
debt they made their bed and need to lay
in it I agree with that on the principle
of loans I think one of the issues is
that you want to make fun of these
gender studies millennials I'm right
there with you I get it but if you also
want these people to snap out of the
Communist socialist ideas and you want
them to get a family recognize why the
taxes are too high start working being
responsible for their own home we need
to clear the path for that that's why my
compromise is the interest rates on top
is where people are really getting
hammered down so you take out a loan for
50 Grand over the course of 10 years
you've paid back 50 but you still owe
50. okay you've already paid back the
principal we gave you maybe there should
be a small interest but it's it's static
it's not compounding and we can get rid
of the higher you know predatory stuff
of course now it's not even keeping it
with the rate of inflation which our
government is also responsible for I
just think we need to end the whole
system out right how about we do this
here's the compromise we end the the
subsidization of universities period
done no more government guaranteed loans
and then we'll work out some kind of you
know interest rate for forgiveness but
if you got the money and you spend it
you got to give it back Tom Garrett used
to be in Congress you've had you've had
time before yeah love Tom to death
um
tubs actually in Ukraine right now oh
wow um yeah with his Excel project so
Tom actually had an interesting idea
when he was in Congress where he said
that if you if you took out student
loans he and Tom was a big believer and
we've got to stop what we're doing with
the predatory lending and all that he
goes but if you take out student loans
we we will we will pay off part of the
student loan but then what it is is you
have to increase the number of years
before you start collecting on Social
Security and so the idea was that it
balanced out and so it wasn't that we
were we were shifting your
responsibility for paying your loan onto
somebody else what we were saying is is
that we're acknowledging that look
people live longer they work longer the
whole deal than when Social Security was
first put in effect so if you want to
voluntarily say I will hold off taking
social security for these many years
well then we can take that out of the
current loan that you you require and so
you can get your life started earlier I
was like that is an that is an
interesting approach that doesn't shift
the burden onto taxpayers and
potentially helps some of the problems
that we have too with some of our rumors
it is however I would predict that would
end up happening there is that the
people have their student loans forgiven
with the agreement that they would defer
their collection of Social Security
would end up forming a political block
later in the Life saying we should be
given Social Security and then the
Democrats would say what a travesty it
is that they're not being given Social
Security and then they would end up
getting it anyway and the cost would be
deferred to everybody we got we got a
good one Jamie McCullough says Elon Musk
actually talked to to Tony Stark in
Avengers about an electric spaceship so
yes I have seen him in the same room as
Iron Man but that also means elon's in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so they
could you know they could they could do
some of that
all right Sonny G says hey Tim I'm a 30
I'm 32 and a first year General a first
generation Mexican-American both parents
came to the us legally I graduated from
high school but could not afford to
attend college so I got a full-time job
I saved up and at 21 purchased my SoCal
home
Bravo so awesome well done and they keep
saying the American dream's not real
that's BS man absolute BS you come to
this country and you work hard you can
succeed they're just lying to convince
people to burn it down because they're
insane
all right Adrian Curry with an excellent
statement you gotta make your own
Chicago pizzas it is so much better
fresh would make it would make great
content I have Tavern thin crust recipes
and a deep dish that is close to tasting
like Lou Malnati's I can send I will
gladly accept your pizza recipes Adrian
and that is how deep dish City on
YouTube was born deep dish City
well we're talking about doing a cafe
I think we're going to do it because I
want to put it next to Starbucks and
then subsidize it so that our coffee
will be substantially cheaper than
Starbucks and higher quality so that
Starbucks will know what it feel knows
what it will know what it feels like
when they put their corporate chain
subsidized by the corporation next to a
mom and pop shop and runs them out of
business
that's what they've been accused of
doing I knew stories when I was in
Seattle there was like a really great
corner or coffee shop and then one day a
Starbucks opens up you know right next
to it
they sell their coffee for three bucks
the mom and pop can't afford that but
Starbucks loses money knowing the
corporation can fund you know and just
cover the cost of this once the Mom and
Pop Shop is put out of business by the
split customer base Starbucks cranks
their prices back up that's what I've
been told that's what I was told I was
told that quite frankly yes okay so you
know fact check that one and if you
haven't
smash that like button also subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends I'm going to read one more here
Hugh Richard Bradshaw says would you
accept a multi-million dollar offer from
Elon to be the CEO of Twitter you
mentioned a random like Joe Rogan what
if it's you since you slayed Vijaya
never
what I would not be the CEO of Twitter
bro be CEO of both you know do Tim cast
do Twitter I I you know what actually
that's a good point I would go in and
say as CEO my first course of action is
the company is now just everything's
First Amendment
and they're going to be like but that
means people are going to post awful
pictures yeah welcome to the internet
web 1.0 baby but with billions of people
I think didn't he pick a CEO I saw that
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member to help support our work
we just hired a new journalist we're
doing new shows we got a bunch of really
fun campaigns planned if you liked what
I did with that Times Square billboard
you're going to love the next bit of
culture jamming I have planned that will
absolutely oh this one's going to rustle
up some feathers quite Fierce I have
more plans and we're going to make
statements we're going to push back on
the cultural establishment and let them
know that we are here and every single
journalist in New York is going to be
screaming and banging on their tables
and there will be nothing they can do to
stop it so with that being said Nick you
want to shout anything out uh just once
again it's been a pleasure hanging out
with all of you can't think of a better
way to spend my Friday great Friday
thanks for coming man what's your
Twitter have any time uh Nick for VA is
my Twitter obviously you know check out
making the argument with Nick Freitas
and at some point I'm I'm going to have
to get you to actually hold the coffee
mug saying Thomas soul is a national you
send it to me right now all right I had
so many people ask me to ask you to do
this oh nice he is a National Treasure
by the way and not allowed to die
probably a Global treasure there it is
Thomas Sowell is a National Treasure and
not allowed to die
Nick for f-o-r yeah not the number four
and where do they get check your show
out what YouTube or podcast Spotify is
there a specific day and time that it
goes live no we don't go live but it's
yeah twice twice a week making the
argument
I'm Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons at a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes
y'all should go check that out subscribe
hit the notification Bell we're gonna
have some cartoons coming out next week
that I think you'll really enjoy I love
you all have a wonderful weekend that
was so quality thank you I can only
comment on how awesome Nick and Sheamus
were I love you guys we love you Chris
you were phenomenal tonight thanks a lot
yeah man thanks Ian I'm looking forward
to working with you again in the future
maybe this sometime uh thanks for
covering for Lydia Lydia I love you I
know you're out there enjoying your
honeymoon have a great night have a
great weekend everyone
thanks so much for hanging out head over
to timcast.com be a member go over to
youtube.com chicken City or go to
chickencittylive.com
a lot of babies doing chicken stuff the
silkies hot chicken and uh
thank you all so much for the support
someone just said Tim the Vijaya Slayer
appreciate it thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time